Ladies and gentlemen,
this is unprecedented occurrence here.
Josh Barnett was on his way and not only
did he run into ridiculous traffic,
but Josh is so gangster.
He drives a 1969 automobile around and
unfortunately got a flat tire.
He drove that bitch all the way up
because it work on.
You could throw that pitch all the way
from Orange County.
You do that on a regular basis.
Yeah,
I bought the thing to be a daily driver,
you know,
and uh,
I got kind of tired of how.
I mean I don't drive anything
passionless,
but I just want to drive an old car.
I,
I just,
I liked the simplicity of it.
I like the noise.
I like the feel of it.
So.
And plus it's not,
it's not anything super special.
It doesn't have a bunch of fancy motard
outbreaks and all.
No,
it's all pretty much old school
technology.
I know exactly what I'm dealing with and
stuff breaks.
I can fix it.
Not a problem.
You don't,
it doesn't bother you.
The,
it takes a long time for those things to
slow down.
Trying to brace,
uh,
you gotta account
for that.
This is true.
Um,
I don't know.
I'm used to driving old cars all my
life.
I've driven a lot worse than this and I
do have a,
I have a rear disk conversion kit,
so it will be four wheel disc brakes.
It's still going to take way longer to
stop and say my challenger,
but I'm okay with that.
Yeah.
Once he drive a modern version of a
muscle car,
like,
oh,
why can't you just do this with a better
interior?
Why can't you do this with like an old
school interior?
Like make it like that.
It's just,
I like a car that can start,
like when you want to start it and start
start.
Sure.
My color turns right over every single
time.
Just go boom.
Just goes.
Just super,
super clean.
So it's runs great.
It's 100 percent reliable.
It's that it is 100 percent reliable and
I'm putting a,
a overdrive tranny in it.
I'm doing things here.
Things are.
And uh,
it will be.
I just want basically a high 14 second
quarter mile car that you can drive
everywhere and never.
Yeah.
And See I can't even enough alone.
It's got.
It's got a peg leg in it right now,
so I got to put a pause unit in it.
That just has to happen.
You are,
you like the quintessential boy turned
man metal music cage fighting muscle
cars.
It's all of the quintessential manly
type shit
somebody ever asked me like,
so.
So what are you really good at?
Doing manly shit.
Making manly faces while I do manly
shit.
Like I can,
I can look inquisitive and I can stare
off in the distance and I can hold a
cigar in my mouth and I can.
I can put grease in the right places.
Yeah.
You gotta cover all as a whole manly
repertoire.
Yeah.
Which is good because it offsets,
you know,
all the Times that I'm wearing panties,
it offsets the society too as a distinct
lack of manliness going on.
It does the uh,
the boobs are not just on the women
anymore.
Yeah,
it's not,
you know,
there's a lot of that.
There's a lot of,
a lot of,
you know,
men are giving into what women like
because if you don't,
you get labeled,
you know,
you,
if you like all the shit that you like,
you get labeled,
you like you're a chauvinist,
your uptake,
there's something wrong with you.
You're a meathead,
you're a metal head.
Know what,
uh,
you get labeled as being someone you
know,
undesirable or slightly immature.
I know,
I love the fact that,
uh,
so I blamed skinny jeans for all that.
But yeah,
skinny jeans are ridiculous.
If you can't sprawl in your pants,
then you shouldn't be wearing them.
If you couldn't throw it,
at least a body kick and your pants,
you shouldn't be wearing them.
You shouldn't be wearing something that
you have to struggle to get out of or in
that shits they're seeing maybe those
chuck norris karate pants,
the karate denims with a gusset crotch.
We'll come back in to round out anybody
in the face.
No problem.
We need to get like a true religion
version of the Chuck Norris Jeans.
Like they need to combine forces,
club pants,
high kicks with the ultimate.
The ultimate Ninja Douche bagger.
Oh,
could you imagine just the commercials
we guys throwing roundhouse kicks with
their,
with their foot slip on shoes and our
fucking heavily monogrammed glittery
shirts.
Throw,
throw in karate,
roundhouse kicks.
But uh,
as far as like labels like I been
labeled all my life.
I wasn't a nerd,
a Dork and I was an outcast kid,
you know,
and I liked weird shit like foreign
films and Gore movies and anime and
comic books and we'd go to the race
track with my family and classic cars
and just all kinds of weird fucked up
shit were,
you know,
I could.
I'm captain of the football team but
nobody else knows what the fuck I what
tip I'm on.
They're just going,
dude,
you're a Weirdo.
Is this where you always attracted to
being into shit that was like away from
the crowd or is that just the stuff that
you liked?
Both.
I mean,
I,
I grew up in that weird era where cable
came about and so they would fill the
airways full of whatever cheap shit they
could get.
And that ended up being a lot of weird
shit,
a lot of weird shit from,
from Japan,
from everywhere.
And then I had a fixation with horror
movies as a kid and that lead to other
places,
you know,
all of a sudden the cycle Friday the
13th is cool,
but I didn't really get to see that head
get crushed.
So where,
where can I pick that up at?
You know,
what movies got that in it.
So yeah,
the faces of death.
Did you get into all that?
Actually I was more into like the
Italian,
like full cheese Zombie movies and stuff
or they're horrible and the dubbing is
the worst ever.
But you know,
people are like vomiting out their
insights,
you know,
vaginas start talking and eating things,
whatever.
If that's a movie,
you should probably see it.
And there was a whole series in like,
I guess it was the sixties and the
seventies of just what they would call
Gore movies.
What movies were unbelievably gory.
Like I remember I picked up a magazine
about at once.
It just,
you know,
it was one of those just looking through
random magazines like what the fuck is
his,
like Fangoria,
and it was all about one type of
Gore film at this one duties to make it
herschell Gordon Lewis,
stuff like that hasn't maniacs.
And I think that's it.
And uh,
the wizard of Gore.
Yeah.
And so he came out,
he,
when they were making like these,
I think they're x rated at the time,
they weren't hardcore but like these,
these exploitation films at one point,
and then it was like,
that wasn't enough.
So they created this movie.
They showed people getting their tongues
cutoff and I mean they're really cheesy,
so bad,
but still starving,
but back then it really fucked people's
minds up.
Yeah.
And uh,
and that was,
you know,
that was just,
that was their new thing.
All of a sudden the audience was flipped
out about it and they had to get more of
it.
Yeah.
I remember seeing that as a little kid
going,
woo,
fuck wants to wash this.
Like this is just disturbing.
Like I understand a good Zombie movie,
a good vampire movie,
you know,
something fun.
Well,
who the fuck wants to watch people just
get chopped up like that.
That's a lot of people know with the,
uh,
with you've got the whole,
um,
what was that?
Uh,
Eli Roth thing,
a torture film.
But they had.
Oh yeah.
Which I can't remember.
They've done.
Two of them I think were the travelers
end up in Romania and then they get into
some place by hobbits.
Hostile.
Yeah.
I only saw the first one.
Right.
And then,
and then of course even the rich people
will pay to the court.
But honestly,
really it's all the women's fault.
The chicks lured them in those course.
Vagina ruins lives.
They,
it certainly can,
you know,
you go up for a piece of strange and you
get a fucking splinters shoved into your
eye.
That's what happens.
It can happen.
No.
And there's no protection for that.
Like they don't make a condom for that
one.
No.
You,
you fought all over the world,
right?
I mean,
if you're a fun Russia,
I have never fallen Russia.
Um,
do you ever hear he's hearing this
description of going to the hospital and
it looked like dawn of he dead bodies
laying out there and just stitching
people up in front of you and you're
like,
what the fuck is going on man?
Love bodies like laying on,
on like vodka probably for an
antiseptic.
Yeah.
And that was during the dark age when
the,
uh,
the Soviet Union collapsed.
So I think times were really fucking
hard there for a long time.
I'm sure there's still some of that to
be found over in Russia because it's
such a difference.
And,
and class at this point it's like the
uber rich and then there's not,
not really a middleclass to my
understanding people.
That's why I'm moving like hostile works
because you know,
you look at these pretty girls and
you're like,
if they were really cold hearted killers
from Russia,
they could sneak you in,
pull your butt cheeks apart until you
died.
I wonder if they really are that people
that are willing to pay people to go
about thinking about all the perverted
shit that we think about.
Right.
And then we go and then we go look up
and watch on the Internet while
masturbating,
so to speak for yourself.
Some of us,
some of us are easily amused.
Uh,
but the thing being is that you can
think of all kinds,
fucked up,
weird fetish and there is at least a
handful of people out there.
They're going to do it.
Anything you can imagine someone's
doing.
I just couldn't imagine someone being
able to organize a place where you could
actually go to torture people.
I feel like somebody is going to tell
this.
This is good.
Okay.
Fall apart.
I just,
I don't,
I don't put anything past humanity is
the most fucked up thing.
And the most beautiful thing is easily
as one of the other.
Have you ever seen the Bohemian Grove
footage?
Do you know anything about Bohemian
Grove?
No.
It sounds like a bunch of hippies.
No,
just the opposite.
A bunch of like banker type dudes and a
dignitaries from foreign countries and,
and like skull and bones type dudes.
They get together and who knows what the
fuck is really going on?
But they have this giant Molek,
the owl God,
and they all dress up in robes.
It's ridiculous.
I mean,
it's been proven that there's a secret.
Sounds like larping,
larping,
larping black factored roleplaying.
Oh,
running around
when these guys that are in skull and
bones and there's a lot of weird,
silly,
ritualistic shit that they are doing.
And apparently they're literally are
people to this day,
I don't mean the Alex Jones broke into
it and it was over a decade ago and
filmed it.
These fucking people are.
They're burning in effigy.
They have sticks wrapped up there,
burning it for the sacrifice of the owl
God.
Man.
This is like,
he's like millionaires and it's
I.
They couldn't have chose something
better than that.
Molex a bad motherfucker,
dude.
Apparently.
I don't know.
I've never.
I know that there are topics carry
everything,
but why not a grizzly bear?
That would definitely be scary than it.
That will totally be scary.
It makes it even gnarlier noise.
I was.
Don't sound scary and it took a long
time from Allah kill you and you
probably would win if you had to go toe
to toe in an owl.
I put my money on myself.
Fuck yeah.
All you need to do is grab a hold of his
neck was not any kind of defenses and
will have not even like a,
it could flesh out whenever we're
talking about what we're talking about
life and death and kill it,
kill it.
But even a small brown bear,
black bear,
I'll fuck you up man.
Kind of bears are scared of you so you
don't have to worry about them as much.
But uh,
you know,
if he wanted to fucking cat man,
30 pound cat,
scary as shit.
I do have a desire,
I don't think I'll ever make it happen
to have like a cougar sized cat is like
my,
my pet.
And I don't mean like pet,
like I want to lock it around on a
leash.
I just want someone to break into my
house while I'm gone.
So you know the,
the variation being,
Oh,
you got your dogs,
they're the Robert Breaks in or whatever
the dog,
they run away.
Well the cat,
the drama breaks in,
she's keeps stealing shit.
Right?
And he's like,
unhooking your TV and all of this and
all of a sudden there's going to hear
that roar from a Puma and it's on his
neck just murdering him.
So you come home and you're like,
oh,
I see you had someone to play with while
I was gone.
They see that if you see a mountain lion
first,
that it's very likely that he's not
going to attack you if you see him
first.
I couldn't believe that a pcs,
you first,
he might not be able to resist it.
You know,
if he knows that you don't know what the
fuck has happened,
that that rush of just creeping up on
you.
And Jack knew bushwhacking speech so
far.
I mean that's what they love.
So what they should do is I should get
mountain lions to be the ones that
spread the gospel of Jesus around
because then nobody would know that they
were around.
They could sneak up on you and I,
Hey,
you haven't been to talk about our Lord
and Savior.
You're like,
fuck,
where'd you come from?
They would do it a little differently
than they would introduce you to them
immediately.
At least if you get killed by a cat
though,
they kill you know,
barriers.
Just start eating it.
Just hold it down and start eating you.
That's,
that's a lot more of a pain in the ass
here.
But that guy in Africa student,
he got eaten by a bear fucked up by
chimpanzees.
Oh,
they dragged him a mile,
dragged him a mile,
beat the fucking shit out of him,
dragged them under a fence and then
dragged them like,
can we blame Kubrick for that?
Well,
these chimps were all problem chimps.
They were all chimps that had been in
zoo's and captivity.
They were trying to reintroduce that CDC
problem.
Champs should be.
Somebody should have a problem.
Chips are,
but they're not.
They're not even wild chimps.
Chimps that they're trying to
reintroduce the wild zoo champs circus
champions.
So they're like,
I needed therapy.
And then these chimps.
Sure.
They finally got issue as well.
A lot of those chimps,
first of all,
I think they get milk,
mental illness,
if you're naturally a supposed to be in
a wild situation where you're all your
instincts are tuned into protecting
yourself,
looking around,
making sure that nothing sneaking up on
you and yet you live in front of a giant
glass wall where every day these weird
pink monkeys are staring at you and your
senses are going off and you have you
don't know what the fuck to do.
He just becomes normal and you get used
to it,
but every day you probably go crazy.
They're probably crazy.
It's completely unnatural environment
because they have the the higher brain
capacity to to to to logically work out
what's going on,
where they're at,
how this,
how this whole deal works and how many
of them are or abused.
I think a lot.
I think a lot of them get abused.
You know,
that's the scenario that took place in
that a planet of the apes movie,
the most recent one was that one guy was
an asshole spraying the champs with the
hose.
I'm sure that happens.
I'm sure they the news,
and I'm sure they're assholes too.
I should.
They do country things and you want to
fucking spray the chimp with a hose.
I wouldn't doubt that for a second.
Have you seen him raping frogs?
Ooh,
yeah.
It's hilarious.
But fuck a frog.
Who put them in.
What they do?
Throw the frog in there at some point.
Like monkey ruthless frog.
I wonder if it was just a natural
occurrence.
The frog just fucked up and wound up
there,
but a lot of them though,
they have like a thing where you can't
climb out.
Yeah.
So I think there's some like 19 year old
zookeeper dip shit.
He's like people and animals.
What a strange combination.
It's going to be real weird if we find
out that something much smarter than us
because we're going to have to figure
out how to convince it to not put us in
a zoo.
I think about the way we treat all this
shit that's just barely a little less.
A little less than us.
I don't think that they would have to be
convinced.
I think we do it to ourselves anyways,
probably reality television.
We're,
we're,
you know,
the idea of sticking out behind a cage
and letting us act like the biggest
assholes we could possibly think of a
generally in New Jersey.
Uh,
then there you go.
It's ratings.
Wonder.
Yeah.
Housewives that shows like a human zoo
and a lot of ways or that's part of the
appeal is that you don't know anybody
like that.
You're not hanging out.
You're not introducing anybody like
those idiots in your life,
but yet you can watch them,
you know,
like the men posturing with each other.
I'm going to call him Joseph Feed.
He's a fucking girl.
That one.
You're like,
whoa.
I do you hear yourself?
This is an actual.
You're a grown man.
Josephine.
That's a pretty complex for calling
another won't really common common and
Jersey Grandmother's name Josephine,
Italian woman's name.
It's very common,
but the guy was joe who's calling
Josephine,
meaning you'd go to a fulcrum,
use a little girl.
I'm cooling.
My girls knew like,
what kind of asshole would you.
I mean,
would you ever let that guy in your
house,
would you ever hang out with him?
If anybody like that was talking to your
house?
He would immediately start mocking them
and you would go get the fuck out of
here.
I'm probably married.
That's your type.
Oh,
I love it.
oiled up.
Spiky hair and lots of,
uh,
lots of big earrings.
Steroids.
Oh,
totally.
To Stop.
Big Hoop earrings.
Those are very important.
Something about the daring dual hoop dj
on the side.
I did the stretch.
Things start happening.
There's two,
I don't know,
I don't know when the plug thing started
happening.
I know like,
I mean there was a piercing kids.
We're into that and it was like a
certain kind of a certain kind of scene
want to do that.
And then like hipsters started doing it
like indie kids are kids and then it
started to grow,
grow,
and then,
well,
and you know,
at some point,
okay,
let's say you don't want to fucking
hearing anymore.
You don't have to wear an earring,
but we just fucking mangled your ear
into some weird grown out disc like once
you get over that,
I don't know.
Uh,
I suppose they like loop it over the
rest of the year.
They cut it back.
I've heard someone say that he can do
whatever.
I'm like,
well,
who wants to go through all of that?
That's a pain in the ass.
And then what did you get?
Staff?
Yeah,
you're stupid.
Yeah.
There's two things that always troubled
me in our culture.
Like how does that get that far?
Because I understand,
you know,
in other cultures have been doing things
for thousands of years and the Thai
stick fucking robots.
You're living in a jungle and I mean,
you're not even trying to be about
modernization.
You're just living your life.
But in this country there's that.
There's the ear thing and then there's
the fucking saggy pants thing,
the saggy pants and kills me more near
thing.
The saggy
pants thing is,
uh,
I can't believe if you came up to me and
the 19 eighties and said these things,
saggy pants are still be around 2012.
There's no way.
It's so dumb.
I can't believe it's here now.
I'm like,
trust me,
it's not going to last.
They don't even know what it's from.
It's from prison.
When the guys are in prison,
they got no belts because they don't
want to commit suicide.
So everyone's sagging their pants.
So when they get out,
they used to doing that.
It's like an ex con thing.
Something cool about it.
Well,
somehow or another it became a rockstar
thing and like you meet guys that are in
bands and they're sagging their pants,
they have their pants buckled up over
there.
I'm like,
what the fuck are you doing?
Are you a gangster?
Are you a basketball shorts underneath?
What is that about?
What is that?
That is a weird.
It's horrible.
And then how about.
And then there's kids with the skinny
jeans,
the practical jeggings,
and they're say like,
there's like a little weird urge to
pants those guy in headbutt them when
you see a dude with the pants,
like really just below their dick,
like this is just,
you're crazy.
You're sprinting and watch me follow
themselves,
walking around amongst people and you
basically look like a slob.
You basically handcuffing yourself and
you're allowing people to close the
handcuffs like you've got this little
thing on.
You can just say we're just pants you
and push you over.
Like,
this is ridiculous.
This is the dumbest thing.
You can be retarded.
What kind of man?
What kind of.
What does that say about our society
that people,
for whatever reason,
this is how they choose to leave the
house.
They want to buckle their pants above
their cock and have their underwear
hanging above it.
What?
No,
that's what you do.
Yeah,
man,
it's dope.
I'm sagging like that doesn't even.
That's got to be some sort of a.
it's an aberration,
like some sort of a.
you'd think so,
but it just continues to exist and
perpetrate and it just still continue to
be.
I see people like that all the time.
I see guys where they buy the jeans.
Sag.
I'm so much that.
And then where the long shirt that it.
It looks like crazy legs or your knees
are two feet long.
That doesn't make any sense.
I mean,
you know what?
I'm not here to talk about fashion for
the most part in terms of like why
didn't mean that in general we want to
talk about fashion.
A politician.
I'm not here to talk about Fascia and my
opponent was talking about fashion.
I want us to tax you for skinny jeans.
Yeah.
Taxi for being a Douche bag is your belt
buckle below your Dick.
You're a fucking idiot.
Okay.
Is Your Dick Above your belt?
Buckle.
You Sir are an asshole.
You need to put your fucking pants off.
You can't possibly be contributing to
society.
How old does that make you feel to have
that very old,
that rant.
Not just old,
but a confused like,
this is not something has happened.
I think
we've lived through arrows and are
familiar with,
with evolutions of fashion as it is and
just we've seen,
yeah,
not nearly as preposterous.
No,
no,
they're not.
And yet and not nearly as offensive
either.
So we started off on from [inaudible]
77,
so I remember when bell bottoms are
still kind of hanging around and fucking
mork and mindy vest,
but like the multicolor them goofy shit.
Right.
And the bowl haircuts but then going
into the eighties and they're like the,
the,
the abstract hairs and the all the
different.
And there was like the,
all the androgynous shit.
There was the super tight stuff.
There was a really colorful stuff.
There's like everything.
The girls that look like Nagel
paintings.
Okay.
I seen all that and then you go to the
nineties and then it just got okay.
Sagging pants and like weird odd colors
and shoulder pads and whatever.
And then the 2000 and then you start.
Now we start combining fashion stuff
from,
from classic era's and Amin all sorts of
stuff is making all kinds of comebacks.
So you're seeing looks from all over the
place everywhere.
Every day,
even right now,
that is the word,
the sagging jeans just that is the.
I just can't get.
I mean
that's the bottom.
That's the least understandable rockstar
on
stage and you're sagging your jeans a
little bit and you're looking like
particular you're deliberately trying to
look like,
like you're a,
like a pile of shit,
like some sort of thrown together.
Just just sloppy son of a bitch on
purpose.
Yes.
Got It.
To a degree when you were like a size 30
waist and you've got 40 genes on and
they're just piled around your ankles
and just what the fuck are you thinking
of buying like quadruplex shirts that
hang down past your knees,
you know who wears shirts that are so
big that it covers their whole body.
Women do when they sleep at night and
I'm not pregnant yet or when they're
pregnant,
they were that.
Or girls wear that when you're like 14
your 90 shirt.
Sure.
Silly Bitch.
Someone's got to pants you.
Someone's got pants.
You push you over and pull your shirt
over the top of your face and then give
you nuggets.
It's ridiculous.
Look,
and I can't believe it's still around,
it doesn't make sense and I think it has
something to do with the fact that we're
not fulfilling our hunter gatherer
jeans.
A hunter gatherer genes are being
ignored.
100 genes,
$100 jeans are sagging our warrior
genes.
They're not being fulfilled,
so we have all these genetic impulses
that are all suppressed and so what do
people do?
What goes off in aberrations and some.
Some aberrations are like sagging jeans.
They do stupid shit because they know
that they're not.
They don't have to work.
If you were out in fucking Alaska and
you were running away from bears all
day,
you would have your belt buckles cinched
in,
have your fucking boots tied,
walk outside the door and you would the
fuck is that.
You wouldn't be like,
yeah man,
you no longer taking cops to put my
pants sagging.
Do they're medicating themselves on
purpose,
leaving medical,
leaving their house dulled.
Why?
Because they're thumbing their fingers.
That given the finger to nature,
right?
You're saying it's so safe.
I can go out with my fucking lap belt
tightening to think of new ways to be an
asshole because I don't have anything to
worry about it anymore dated,
going outside,
not worried about sleeping on a park
bench,
you know,
worried about animals coming up and
eating,
you know,
animals out here,
the pigeons,
that's it.
You're going to worry about shit and
they're not doing a damn thing with God.
Dammit.
We thumbed our nose and the face of
evolution,
and this is the.
This is the system we found.
Yeah,
the,
the easier things get,
the weaker we become,
the more we started looking for new and
other ways to try and express that which
is not be used at all and not that I'm
saying everybody needs to go out and
start getting a fistfight,
drinking whiskey and,
and being fucking heavy metal bat.
I like myself,
but do something.
Do something difficult.
So your character,
anything difficult,
anything like to start by let's say
maybe want using definite,
definite a definite words.
When you speak,
stop saying like kind of sort of.
I sat there and listened to a cable
guide connecting my myself saying,
well you kind of do this,
and it's like that,
and it's,
what do you mean?
It's kind of in like you fucking hit the
enter button and it absolutely
positively chooses set thing that you
fucking put the cursor on this not kind
of,
it's not sort of,
it's like it's a filler.
It's,
it's,
it's another,
but now it's come in,
you don't want to commit to anything.
Nobody wants to deliberately say I'm
going to be there at this time and I'm
going to fucking be.
There was a kind of maybe,
you know,
no one ever wants to also be deliberate
in their speech because what they say
I'm going to go.
And I,
I think that uh,
that black is the new gray and then
someone goes,
what?
No,
no.
And they disagree because you made a
definite statement.
You took a stand,
you made yourself,
you know,
and I think black is the new.
Great,
fuck you.
If you think differently,
fine,
we're going to get into an argument
about it.
I might run you over with my fucking
car,
whatever,
but this is how I feel about it.
If you say I kind of thing that I get to
name,
it gives you that wiggle room that you
can fucking slinkier way out.
You can use your greased up and slide it
under the door kind of.
And I fall.
It's such a common part of speech at
this point that even I find myself
saying like,
and kind of here and there,
but I can't stand it.
I hate when I catch myself saying like,
I'm not,
I'm not all about the like either,
but you know,
kind of this sort of that and no,
it isn't kind of or sorta anything.
Lots of shit in this world is not Kinda
sorta.
It just is.
So you can't,
you can't get away from that.
Just fucking deal with it.
So uh,
you know,
that's just a huge pet peeve of mine
dealing with people on a regular basis
because it's,
it's so much easier for someone to think
of things.
Always have the ability to excuse
themselves from it.
So that way they don't ever have to take
the brunt of the responsibility either
way,
reason for not liking that and other
people's that you would hate to see ever
in yourself.
It's an.
It's a weakness we've all been seeing.
Yeah,
well done.
Those things are all done.
Bullshit.
Stuff like that.
I think the difference being is when you
realize that that was bullshit.
Yeah.
You learned.
And some people aren't learning some and
that's,
that's where they need to.
Someone needs to kick him in the ass.
Somebody needs to say,
listen,
you got to catch the fuck up.
Right?
You learn from your mistakes and then
improve and move on.
It's not just a continual cycle of
failing and trying to get back on the
horse and failing.
It's learned how to ride a fucking
horse.
Okay?
It's not how many times you fall off the
horse.
Don't fall off the fucking horse again.
Stupid.
Train the Horse,
right?
Ride the horse right and don't fall off
the horse.
You could be Christopher if you keep
falling off horses,
especially if you want to get a horse to
jump over some shit that he doesn't want
to jump over.
I will never understand that
and it's.
You know what?
It is a lot to say that you could master
an animal like that,
but it is a massive fucking animal and
when he doesn't want to do what it wants
to do,
like how are you?
How do you think it's great that we can
use our intellect to control this thing,
but when it came down to the physical
aspects,
like you can't make a fucking horse do
what it doesn't want to know.
Pullover shifts.
One thing,
if you run a trail horse,
you want the horse to ride on the trail
horse with a 200 pound man on his back.
It's really not that big a deal for a
horse and they can safely walk.
But you want a horse to jump over shit.
You want it to fly through the air with
a person the back.
Okay.
You fucking crazy.
What?
What's what?
What if you ever tried?
There's a lot of other shit,
you know,
fucking take a martial arts class,
learned how to drive a race car and race
cars are great.
They have breaks there.
They're fantastic.
They learn how to steer the very
predictable.
It's not a fucking animal.
Some crazy might of its own.
It just wants to jump for whatever
reason,
wants to fuck you back.
He lands on you and crushes your scholar
rock.
How about that?
The rest of your life,
you've.
If you have a window the size of a
quarter that you could see the world out
of and you're fucking shitting your
pants.
That's not anything that I'm interested
to.
This is what I shoot all horses on site.
Have you ever had some of those Alistair
overeem?
More steaks?
No.
No,
no.
I haven't worked my way up.
I'm more of a goat.
Dick Guy.
The whole heavy metal attitude.
A little spicier.
It's supposed to be really a delicious.
Actually I have had horse meat into then
at Bra.
Did you like.
Oh really do wrong.
Yeah.
It's like a horse that she needs like a
delicacy over there,
especially in like tissue in the more
southern prefectures,
but I just,
it doesn't.
Uh,
I didn't dig it.
Alright.
And then what does Johnston?
I'm a is,
it kind of gave me kind of Gamey.
It's,
I couldn't really.
I'd be like sort of a taste maybe closer
to that.
Uh,
but I like Venice,
love Venice.
Uh,
it's just,
it's a little
man.
I'm amazed how hard it is to get
venison.
You would think like really like.
Yeah.
You think like these are fucking pretty
prevalent animals.
Why is it someone breeding them?
Like around here,
you know,
I mean
somewhere in the valley or something.
That big fucking field of because thing,
it's worth a shit.
Was hard enough to get to get assholes
in Hollywood as it is.
And then then you go ahead and then you
want to deliver something like,
okay,
they're gonna eat cow.
They'll eat chicken.
Definitely fish.
I was just making fun of somebody in the
day.
Where do you want to to Sushi?
Oh,
of course you want to go to such a let's
get a Sushi.
I love Sushi.
I'm like,
God,
give me some like,
oh,
have you ever been to a Sushi
restaurant?
Like what the fuck?
Why does every woman in la?
Why don't eat fucking raw fish?
Why do you think that is?
Because it's what other,
what they think every other woman in La.
Those really.
Yes.
I thought it was because it was now me.
It's good,
but it's not like fuck,
let's go eat Sushi.
Like fuck that.
Like you don't wake up one day and just
think,
okay,
I might use to want fish.
I just want to say yes to everything
man.
So I,
I forced me and it was all right.
But uh,
um,
what do you even like the other one
thing he like almost above everything
else during your,
in your diet or you'd be fairly clean,
like nutrition minded or flavor?
Uh,
try to be both.
I mean,
I do really enjoy the red meat hamburger
or steak or you can do a lot.
It's pretty personal too with that,
right?
Yeah.
So most satisfying food.
But one thing is,
okay,
there's that,
or if I just had some serious piece of
ass,
the very next thing I want to hand to
the next thing I want is a fucking him
I've,
I've left.
I've left departments at odd hours of
the night just tracking down any 24 hour
Carl's Jr and Jack in the box because I
need a fucking hamburger immediately.
I'm done with the late night hamburgers.
I switched over,
I try to use,
I tried to eat some chicken sandwiches.
I'll eat like a carl's jr chicken
sandwich or something like that.
But the progress,
it's either in and out or Wendy's and
the other tapping out.
I can't.
I can't do Mcdonald's burgers too.
I don't,
I don't almost.
I almost never eat any of that crap.
I'll be honest.
Like I,
if I'm going to have a burger,
there's plenty of places I could go that
I know that meat is a lot healthier and
I understand also the idea of keeping
costs at those so far overboard in terms
of what corporations is people try to do
to save a buck.
Basically you through all integrity out
the window,
so I can't support them
that.
What is that?
That's not even a burger.
You've seen those pictures where they
could take a Mcdonald's burger and then
they track it for six months and it
doesn't rot,
which just sits there.
I heard I did read about that because my
buddy did the same thing in his gym,
a crossfit breath.
He took the Bergens,
left it there and it didn't.
And then I read something about,
well,
it's got so much salt in it,
so it's more of a salt thing.
Really.
They said the weirdest thing about it
isn't really the Burger.
It's thought that thing,
not molding.
That's where that's the most fucked up
part of the whole thing and you should
really be the most worried about putting
that in your mouth.
Really that phrasing,
I figured that a piece of bread,
I mean you can,
you can salt meat to a degree that you
know,
that it keeps for a long time.
They've been doing that forever,
but I mean long before we had
refrigeration,
all meat with salt and pretty much so.
And you can make it into Jerky,
that bond,
we don't really write.
It doesn't have that kind of shelf life.
What is the effort,
what are they putting in there?
So insane preservatives,
I don't know,
something,
something totally Ireland that you
really probably shouldn't be putting in
your body.
It's amazing.
But in order to feed the amount of the
amount of people that we have packed in
the cities,
like you just drove here from Orange
County,
think of that crazy drive which is one
of the worst drives in the country as
far as population centers.
I mean that is an enormous amount of
people from the four.
Oh,
five for the five.
That whole area is,
that's an incredible amount of pain
you're going through
through all these different demographics
the whole way.
And the only food.
Everybody needs food.
I think that there is a.
I'm like,
okay,
Penn and teller,
I love watching of filler bullshit.
And they had their whole thing on
organic food and about how uh,
you know,
the various chemicals also determined
whether it's something can be called
organic or not,
but then some certified or things that
can be considered organic in terms of
pesticides are actually worse than that
than the things that they've created
since then.
Well fine,
but it's that fine line where if you
like,
you can take it to this point.
Okay.
To a degree.
But people take it that,
you know,
they want to save that extra thirty
cents on the dollar while,
or three cents on the dollar and cent on
the dollar and pink slime.
That should just never be.
It should just never be excellent.
Yeah.
That,
that,
that pace that they throw into the
burgers.
Oh yeah.
Normally,
yeah.
Like all the really gnarly treated with
like ammonia see you kill all the
bacteria that's in it.
It's like the idea that that's a burger.
It's ridiculous that in a burger.
Have you seen,
what would they do to fast food burgers?
The fillers and all the different things
they have.
I love,
Oh fuck out.
Or I'll have a three by three.
Would you like five guys?
Five guys.
Five guys?
Pretty fucking good.
I might like that better than out on
your button.
Yeah,
my buddy was going in and out.
It's better.
I think I will say that there
equal,
pretty fucking bad ass.
Can we just say separate?
Different.
Separate but separate sequel.
They're equally delicious
in a different way.
I'm a big fan.
I'm A.
I'm really on a hunt to find the best
ultimate cheeseburger you can get
anywhere and a mommy's definitely got a
great one.
Father's office was fantastic and I'll
the whatever you know the 12 bucks on a
hammer
in Atlanta called the laughing skull and
they got some cheeseburger place,
apartment.
That is God.
I can't remember if you remember that
place.
Brian.
The laughing skull plus the cheeseburger
place.
Hadn't remember.
Torsions fusion.
Fusion,
I think.
I don't remember.
Whatever it is.
If you're in Atlanta,
it's above the laughing,
so it's the fucking greatest
cheeseburger place on the face of the
earth.
He had like all great buffalo burgers
with blue cheese and just gore may slam
and cheeseburgers.
Real meat cooked the way you want.
You want it rather than giving you a
rare.
You want a medium,
right?
Right.
Trust,
trusted.
It's like,
oh,
it was so awesome.
There's a place in Chicago I got to get
to.
It's all heavy metal theme called
coolest corner.
Have a slayer burger or go burger later.
The minute listen,
a good horror burger.
It was.
It was like a.
It was like a lamb patty or something
with ground beef sirloin and these are
like gourmet,
like pretzel rolls a with goat cheese on
top.
I mean to to to put like the layer that
entire one has these,
these sauteed a pear slices that have
been thrown on top of Gorgonzola and all
this,
I mean just damp and you have dirty
metal heads in there listening to know
immortal and then they're just counting
the greatest burgers.
Never known world.
Well,
weird combination and the Jews like in a
death metal and exquisite gourmet
burgers.
Yeah.
That's so rare.
Exactly.
Why not go there?
How did you become a big death metal
head?
Started off just getting into metal from
the classic rock side of things and my
dad used to play guitar and just for fun
like Blues and Classic Rock and grew up
listening to Sabbath and led Zeppelin
and the Beatles and what have you.
And then I found like this kid that was
the son of where my babysitter,
he was in,
he introduced me basically to I made.
And that was like,
oh fuck yeah,
of course at like six years old seeing
Eddie.
The mascot was the coolest thing ever.
Like seen iron gate.
It's like a monster look in Zombie
thing.
They call him Eddie.
And I remember he had this killer's
shirt for the new album killers and
Scott and he's like holding like some
limp woman in his hand with like a
bloody hatchet in the other spot that is
so bad ass.
And then I remember like,
and then from there with like metallica
and slayer and negative and anthrax and,
and uh,
and then that progressed to,
I remember hearing simple Hoorah.
And that was harder and heavier.
And then I found this pan bolt thrower
and I'm like,
what the fuck is that?
The covers are so amazing and they're
from these games like whammer 40 k
stuff,
something like that.
I already liked that.
So let me check this out.
Oh God.
This is the heaviest,
most crushing music I've ever heard.
It sounds like.
Sounds like an entire army of guitars
coming up over the top of a ridge.
And then all fisk fucking you all at
once.
Pretty much on Marshall amps.
Dropped out of the sky continuously on
top of yours.
Raining on you being written by like
trolls.
Is that the kind of Shit you listened to
you in your car?
Blew my tire out though.
I'm playing the music.
Oh it didn't?
No,
he didn't know what you said.
You listen to them when you work out.
I listened to it all the time,
but it's.
It really depends on my mood so I can
listen to.
The only thing that I'll have on my ipod
is country music.
Really?
I can't get with country music.
You'd ever heard you?
No.
Reagan.
Bob Marley.
I could probably buy one reg,
a compilation album and have all the
essentials for any reggae song ever
created ever.
And I'm okay with this.
Like 10 really good ones.
Right?
Would you be loved?
That's a great gym.
Yes.
That's a great jam.
Stand out to you
that get up.
Stand up.
Yeah,
but it gets a little repetitive
and I,
you know,
I've heard it said like,
okay,
got it.
Got It.
All right.
Now what are you seeing about today?
I and I.
What?
All right,
cool.
Yeah,
but at least it's better than Hawaiian
music.
Hawaiian.
They're very proud people and I would
understand if you got offended and when
I go to Hawaii next time when people are
pissing me,
but the reality is you're there.
You had a perfect rock,
new orleans,
the perfect climate and the most
beautiful place in the world,
and you're playing a song like the red
and green button will all this shit you
can be playing right now.
You could be playing a whole lot of
love.
You can be playing led Zeppelin.
Okay?
You guys can have acd,
skinner,
you.
You'd be playing some real fucking
music.
This is ridiculous.
How has this not been changed by the
introduction of a song?
That song go that song?
She can.
It sounds ridiculous.
Uh,
all the great songs,
but it's like,
well,
I island things,
you know?
Yeah.
Oh,
Jesus always cracked me up is as you
look like a magazine and her flying to
Hawaii for the first time,
it will fight super raw 13 and I'm
looking through the inflight magazine
and it's got a little section for all
the music and felt like,
oh,
here's the look,
you know,
channel four locals and you look and
there was like this gnarly big jacked up
to,
to the big handlebar,
the gnarly biker mustache or whatever.
It's like food for Luther is his name
and spelling.
You listened to his music.
The sweetest boys ever.
I've been
blowjobs or like right in the morning
with Strawberry Syrup,
all I'm just tripping shoulders.
He does a,
pulls them out of socket because he's
like 470 pounds,
eight feet tall and used to play for the
NFL.
It's just bad music for the greatest
place on earth warrior culture to chill
music.
It's all good.
That killed those red and green bananas.
Shit.
Take five minutes while resting scares
me about the fucking hilarious though.
Oh,
that would be cool.
Maybe it's the navy.
It was a strategy to keep people from
moving to Hawaii.
Just keep putting that shit in music and
I get tired of this music because if you
were like on the beach and they're like
the best bands in the country all were
in Hawaii.
You're like,
why don't we live in
cool.
That's awesome.
And the dirty upset,
right?
You spend a lot of time on why a lot of
people get upset.
They're not happy about all of us.
How he's coming down there or actually
really anybody from the mainland,
they're just like,
why don't you stay there
really?
Even if you're a Hawaiian blood from
them.
Any live in the wetland.
Yeah,
I can't.
I can't speak on that,
but as far as if you're just not
Hawaiian,
she ever lived there?
No.
I spent time there and amazingly a why
were great to me.
I Love Hawaiian island cultures at
large.
I think part of it is because I'm from a
place like Seattle and I have some
country roots to me in terms of like I
grew up,
we'd go hunting and race cars and just
all kinds of redneck.
He asked Shit in addition to any of this
high art bullshit that my mom got me
sort of weaned on and love like modern
architecture and culture and the
classics and reading,
but I'm a fucking down there.
They're like,
oh no,
you're really down to earth who?
You're cool.
You're all right now.
You're,
you're cool.
You're a Allie.
The rest of those fuckers.
Well,
sure.
I mean if he,
he will see the average douchebag,
American tourists,
you know,
route.
I wouldn't.
Yeah.
I wouldn't want them to fucking crush
reader.
Especially.
A lot of people who are emotional and
fork and spoon was one of those Jersey
Douche bags because you imagined most
jersey shore type or housewives of
Jersey type of Douche bags or you can
even take the Jersey shore,
the west coast from Heineken.
One of those assholes around down there,
bro.
Bro.
Bro,
perfect.
That was a really good impression of one
of those asshole say bro.
17 times and every sentence you want me
to show the fuck out,
get more tribal task.
We need to get those motherfuckers in
the gym and then it get strangled and
need to get humiliated.
They need to get down to earth like calm
the fuck down
and just be a little nicer taste.
So much more than that because so many
guys,
especially on the west coast now,
the west coast,
each bag,
they go to the gym every now and again.
They definitely live.
You go there,
they go to plays or whatever they do.
They train,
train Joko to use
and they get in there and they never
really fight a little bit.
Not Fighters.
They're just guys that had a couple of
fights.
The big difference,
but
you're getting humbled and humiliated in
the gym
because outside of the gym like,
well,
that's a different place as a whole
other that's a sort of country that only
exist there and then when I'm out in the
general populace,
when I'm being an asshole on the streets
of of like main street and end and Pch,
that's.
It's different.
That's the big problem that there is a
lot of those guys,
right?
There isn't a Douche.
Bags are douchebags of average downer.
I've leveraged honoring every Douche bag
has this has this thing.
You got your history Douche bag that
thinks they're so above you and there's
culture and everything they say has so
much meaning behind it,
so much deeper.
It's like,
no,
you're just as bullshit.
Anybody else?
In fact,
more so because you don't even realize
that they should.
You say it doesn't matter or you know
you've got.
You've got the MMA douche bag like runs
around wants me to make sure everybody
knows that they train and that it can
fly and all that kind of bullshit and
you've got your club each day.
You've got bags of all sorts.
Not everybody takes it as money.
Douche bags.
There's fitness Douche bags,
just fitness to stretch your grade.
You can't even have a conversation about
anything but their diet.
I mean,
that's wonderful.
That's how I want to spend the next 30
minutes sitting at a table with someone
that's talking about how many like
grains of rice they can have and
everything.
And it's for like,
like a,
a,
it's competition.
Like what are you doing?
Well,
it's like,
you know,
you sort of do a,
different poses and you know,
you do like maybe a little bit of
gymnastics.
Like cheerleader seems a lot like
cheerleading,
man.
What are you doing?
A fitness competition with a megaphone,
you support the team.
It's just ridiculous bodies.
But even with,
if the minute they step off the stage
like that,
I've had an elegant or they.
It's like,
hey,
how you doing?
Hey,
what's up?
Oh,
you're a mom.
You're like,
oh,
I don't know.
I don't want to talk about,
you know,
boneless chicken breast.
No,
I,
you know what I'm here for.
I've got somewhere to be,
but I'll be right back.
Don't worry about that.
It didn't supersized in the morning
thinking about hills.
Fucking do it.
I don't want to talk about it.
How was the.
How could anybody consider that to be
something interesting?
Oh yeah.
We have that.
We have an understanding and that I know
a secret that is
it for entertainment.
Never understood.
People that are into like I can
understand wanting to be in shape,
but I can understand like crossfit
competitions and stuff like that
to be the best in the world of working
out and be the best in the world at
doing cleans,
you know,
Olympic.
No,
no 100 cleans in a row with 50 pounds.
You know,
like we need to know what's going on
here for bodybuilding.
So is like,
okay,
hold on.
Everybody has a,
you know,
they're using the way that they're going
to live for a specific purpose.
Now I'll say I think bodybuilding is
pointless.
What's the point of putting all that
time and effort to look at it?
Just look a certain way.
I never use it.
And then you've got the crossfit,
which is the same thing,
exact same thing,
but just they're an actual better
overall shape and you know,
they use it,
but they only use it for more working
out.
So we're basically just jerking off the
whole time.
That's all anybody is doing.
They're just jerking themselves off and
uh,
you know,
okay,
well why don't you body build because
you know,
you to look better on screen or do power
lifting because you want to be stronger
and then do crossfit,
whatever workout for your anaerobic
endurance animal and all this.
And then like take it and then go play a
game.
Go play football with your friends or go
hiking or climbing a mountain or
grappling or something like that and
then apply it into a skilled deal.
I saw this video where there was,
it was the gist of it was these two nfl
dues are boxers are very.
Nfl guys are former NFL.
They just come from facts and they did
some prostitute workout,
some crossfit gym in La and they did an
x amount of time then.
And here's our crossfit guys that are
here all the time that the kids did it
faster than the other guys.
And I'm like,
but they can catch a fucking football.
You can just run around with a little.
He's like an asshole.
That's all you can do.
You can do 100 kipping pull ups.
Great.
So a great.
Well let's just stop you from no one.
You know what?
100,000
people are not going to fall into a
stadium and pay millions of dollars for
Washington.
Pull ups are about someone trying to do
something and someone else trying to
stop them from doing something.
So multifaceted.
Sort of the competition when you're
dealing a bunch of chips.
No stopping you.
It says you have chefs and it's,
it's kind of a weird halfway sport.
I'm going,
I can see how it's athletic or conceal
requires willpower and discipline.
Amazing Shit.
And it's impressive when got incredible
shit.
But I would rather,
I would rather learn a martial art.
I would rather learn how to play a game.
I'd rather learn to do rather learn
hockey anything.
It's just kind of be more input.
There's more going on than just standing
there doing cleans.
I can't.
I don't get it either.
I,
I think like that's the you do to make
you help you be better at the real thing
that you do.
Yeah.
I was talking to.
I slept competition,
competition in class.
Take some intermural basketball.
We do something we were talking to play,
go play a tournament.
Do crossfit,
be in shape and Api the way these days
shape and an API it don't,
don't go run around the whole world
about it.
So like don't look at other somebody
else and be like,
well when I did that,
you know francine and I did Zelda.
I did it 17 minutes and that's it.
I don't care.
No name,
name,
name Tommy and rescue and Nikki's deck,
like a righteous indignation when they
order the green tea at starbucks.
But that's.
I don't even.
And I think the root,
all that kind of stuff isn't doing.
Crossfit isn't doing any.
It couldn't be any.
You could substitute crossfit with
anything else.
It's just something comes along.
It gets to a certain level where people
start jumping on it because one,
whether it's good or it's bad,
it's something that's new and it's
different and it and it and it is a
change from what the norm was,
so therefore everybody feels like
they're like they're improving who they
are,
they're they're growing and now they're
a part of something that's more special
and therefore then that by a group gets
taken way out of context and then the
after effects of that are people
becoming Douche bags
mathematically,
Broadway,
lot of Nice people and there's a lot of
people that don't want to just go to the
gym and lift weights and be bored,
so they take the shitty stuff.
Of course there's good stuff
not working out and staying healthy is
awesome.
I love that crossfit is as looked back
to older,
simpler ways of training and brought
that to the,
to the,
to the populace.
I think that's great.
You know,
strongman type stuff,
old schools,
the old school thought processes of
just,
you know,
grab heavy shit and lifted,
but you know,
there's a lot of flawed reasoning in my
opinion.
Behind some of that too,
and also like I get so sick of it.
Oh I,
you know,
I'm saying like a fighter,
like,
no you're not,
you're not a fighter.
It's not the same trying to choke the
life out of you brain,
you know,
and if you go to kickboxing class at
night,
that doesn't make you a fighter either.
Like fighters are fighters,
people that do martial arts,
martial art,
you know,
the train training is know what,
just be realistic and there's nothing
wrong with that.
If you're not going to be a fighter,
even though you've trained in martial
arts,
that's okay.
People talk to me about coming and
trying to jam or or whatever.
And I said,
you know what?
Don't do it because you want to be a
fighter.
If you really want to be a fighter,
the fighter,
not a fighter,
to,
to every level that you need to,
which these,
you're probably never going to amount to
anything with fighting because it's.
The odds are totally against you,
but that's not the reason you do it.
Not Because of success that you think
are going to get from it.
You do it because you're driven and you
love it and you have to do it and that's
the only way that you can ever fully
realized that most of your potential.
More people are going to fail,
then they're going to succeed,
but honestly if you are better when you
end it and when you started and you
don't have any regrets and you
absolutely succeeded,
you didn't get the metals you need to
get the money,
but you took you as you stood here today
and became something better and more
encompassing and have lived a life
experience because you decided to do
something and do it like you mean it.
And that's hard for people to wrap their
heads around that,
you know,
I go into the gym,
I just want to be better than when I
step off of that than I was when I
stepped on it.
And some days aren't so great.
Some days are amazing and I also have
like this huge mean streak.
I hate losing whatever,
but I also.
And as much as that is always a part of
who I am,
uh,
I have to temper that and I have to look
at all the data that comes from
everything that I do when I'm in the gym
and then break it down and then be more
effective.
But I think that guy he used up,
do,
you know,
I mean,
yeah,
in my head I'm thinking I'm going to jab
the living shit out of that fucker until
his Dick Falls off.
That's how much I'm going to jab that
period.
I'm going to jab in so many times and
he's never been to want to get in the
ring with me ever again.
Ever.
Period.
You think this is about training?
Yes,
but I also have to sit back,
but I'll go,
why was he able to Jab me?
What did I do wrong?
But I do,
right?
Why is this so effective?
How do I take that and make it mine?
Or how do I analyze that and see the
patterns before they become a problem
for me,
isn't it in the development of a martial
arts to see someone set an incredibly
high level and realize that that is
where the market set
can be the best at everything.
There's somebody out there,
there's probably plenty of people out
there that I can just annihilate and
uses the toothpick with their user bones
as tooth toothpicks when I'm done with
them,
chances are they're out of that group of
people that I'm talking about therapy
within that there's things that they do
better than I do that maybe that one
thing or maybe a couple of things,
but they're better at it by far so I
could look at them and paste something
from.
It doesn't matter how much better of a
fighter I am.
There's so much to be to be seen or
taken in.
There's a million ways that the body can
move and one way you know,
and I realized that there's some things
I'm never going to be great at because
the physicality,
physical limitations or injuries or
whatever,
it's just that's okay.
Like I'm never going to get with rubber
guard because my knees are too fucked
up.
What's wrong with you?
I have torn ligaments sent home and
they're just a mess.
This has been repaired on the right
before and it was just,
they won't take it if I pull on him
through our like that,
it'll start.
It was sent out to like lock master.
That's a man that's got to be kind of
tricky to be a dry with no injuries and
be a guy.
I just need a.
I just have a very good feel for it and
I know what I can get away with and I
know a lot of like lost her ankle goes
before it needs to be.
Oh my ankles are not the greatest thing
either.
But um,
he's just sort of understand what you're
dealing with and then go from there.
But I have nonetheless,
since I know that I'm never going to be
someone that can affect it,
like be a good rubber guard guy.
I pay attention because Shannon like to
use those setups.
So she's working on something.
I can go to her and go,
okay,
look at you,
you know,
get angled like this because look at the
way that,
that pushes your body weight and your
pressure against their joint there and
this,
and this is where now you're creating a
weakness in them at this angle,
so you can defeat that angle here.
Or Hey,
this guy's really good rubber guard.
Now Watch how he's going to.
He's going to try and get these angles
and these positions on you because this
is where it's going to take you out of
position.
So this entire you're going to have to
defeat them because fulcrums levers,
it's all relative.
If you work on your flexibility,
what I do,
it's hard.
It's hard to get there.
And I'm,
I'm older.
And how much of a fighter success do you
think is a timing issue?
Like getting involved in a sport at the
right age time?
Good.
Excellent.
Something.
How much of it is bulldog determination
and just your ability to learn from your
mistakes and despite the bad feelings,
it's mental,
mental,
mental aspect of it.
Uh,
because that's kind of the mental aspect
is the thing that is going to not only
make you want to fight when you want to
quit,
but it'll also be a step back and
realize that all these things,
all these circumstances came about
within these moments and how to take
them,
change them,
understand them and make the appropriate
changes and additions crashes from your
game to be better.
You have to be analytical like that and
you have to remove emotion from that,
from those circumstances because when
she get emotionally attached and worked
up about it,
then it will defeat your ability to be
as useful as possible.
And like,
I mean,
especially in the case of a lot of
people,
most people are never going to be really
successful with fighting if they choose
that as their,
as their,
a pair occupation,
you know,
it's not going to make the money for
them to pay one.
It's not,
but it shouldn't hurt somebody.
They should just do it because they love
it.
I was watching a lecture by Alan,
depending,
I think his name is,
and I'm like that on pessimism.
The philosophical lecture on pessimism
and about how one of the reasons why you
get so upset about things and you get so
worked up is because you have these
expectations that things are always
going gonna work out well,
but if she put the reality of most,
don't work out at all.
In fact,
there's almost always more failure than
there is success,
but you're so primed for success.
You have to believe that this will
always work in your favor and it's like
a traffic.
You know,
you get so mad and angry and pissed off
line and we only traffic,
but the thing is is that there's always
traffic.
Traffic is the,
the,
the not the exception.
It isn't the norm.
So when you encounter it,
why is he so mad?
It's always there and it always occurs,
so it's more unusual for there to be any
traffic at all,
but we have this concept in our head
that even getting behind the wheel and
driving down the road,
it's all gonna work out for us instead
of us having to waste just like every
other schmo because things are the way
they are.
Yeah,
that's a funny way of looking at it.
Um,
we,
we can't,
uh,
one thing I can appreciate failure as a
tool for success,
you know,
because every time that I've ever,
especially as a comedian,
one of the best,
most motivating factors is bombing on
stage.
And when you,
when you eat a dick on stage,
you never want that to happen again.
And you'll tighten everything up.
You'll go over your material with a fine
tooth comb.
Think about your delivery,
you listened to recordings.
He don't want that feeling.
How long does it joke suck before it
becomes good?
You never know,
man.
You never know.
Sometimes you'll come up with a joke and
it's perfect the moment it comes up.
And then other times it might take a,
a,
a year for Joe to evolve.
And remember,
I'm Louis Ck was telling me that Chris
Rock,
Chris rock has this one really
controversial bit.
He goes,
ah,
I love black people.
I hate niggas you ever heard that bit?
I don't think I have
brilliant bit about,
uh,
you know about it,
you know,
the difference between a,
in his mind,
a black guy.
And a Nigga and um,
it,
it took a long time to work.
Apparently it took like a year.
It was bombing for a year.
He would go on to an each,
couldn't get it to work and then it
became eventually became a closing bit.
It became a bit that it was just
destroying perfect old school.
Classic bit.
But it's one of those things where every
bit's got its own timeline.
Every bit has its own shelf life to some
bits are timeless and some bits they're
only good.
They're a monster for six months.
Maybe it's topical.
Maybe things change can make a joke
about vhs tapes anymore.
Nobody gives a shit thing.
Time moves on,
you know.
I mean,
I used to have a great joke about nextel
phones.
It was a fuck about next time.
No,
it's uh,
some of them will last for a long time
and some of them don't.
And some of them are done the moment you
say it,
the first time on stage,
that's its lifespan.
It's funny.
Only the first time hearing it.
Sure.
Is it.
There's some of that and there's some
bits that are there are fully formed bit
the moment out of your mouth and the
last few years it's totally different,
you know,
just uh,
it completely depends on the subject,
depends on what you're trying to say,
how,
how silly or complex it is.
Usually the more common
has I imagine also what bits led into
that.
Sure,
yeah.
Bits go from exile and what not just
jokes being said,
but what tone is being set,
so all of a sudden you're going one
direction.
You change gears.
Sometimes that immediacy hard stop,
changed,
catches people off Guard and reserve any
and it makes them laugh or at least you
know,
it gets their mind spinning in a way
that sets up the next stuff.
Or sometimes it just confuses them and
flux the whole rest of the next,
you know,
10 minutes of jokes up.
Just knowing that you can be a comedian,
could easily be a community.
Just having this conversation and
knowing that I always tell people that
you get,
it's nothing.
It's not that complicated,
but it's not easy.
A,
it's a weird.
I've never been to,
a comedian was a,
was sitting with a friend who was a
comedian and they were going to go on
and on.
I'm just hanging in the pre show and
we're all,
a bunch of us were all just hanging out
in the,
uh,
in the Iowa and I'm just being the crack
and stupid jokes and doing wordplay and
whatever.
Someone was like,
you know,
you work in at night.
I'm like,
I got a little boehner and I was like,
very little.
And uh,
and I just thought,
no,
I'm not a comedian at all where you
think I'm fucking,
I like that you can do it.
It's not that complicated.
It's a,
you know,
it's almost like a normal skill that
everyone sort of has a small form.
Most people at least try to have like
one or two things they could say that a
witty in their life,
you know,
it's just a matter of cultivating those
and becoming like a woody farmer.
And I say,
how many people can keep their nerve too
though.
It's a little of that.
Yeah.
If I had to get on stage and deliver
stand up,
that would would freak me the fuck out
would be more.
That's more way more fearful than
fighting even five guys all at one time,
like that's okay by me,
but once you do it a couple times,
it would be easy.
Dude.
I have been in some of these public
speaking scenarios where people are so
great.
I go,
I'm shitting myself.
So scary.
It's crazy.
Shitting yourself.
It doesn't make any sense,
I guess.
No real fear.
Exactly,
and that's,
that's,
that's a hard thing to get past is that
in my mind,
I know that that all this fear is all
self created.
If everybody thought I was an idiot,
who cares?
Right?
It only matters what I think.
If I don't think I'm an idiot and I'm
okay with it,
then fuck you all like go,
go fucking.
You can all burn.
I don't get that shit.
Take a long time to get to the point of
comfort filled.
That is part of being a man and one of
the most important parts of being a man
is getting to a point where you
genuinely,
truly don't give a fuck if someone
doesn't like what you like.
It was like,
I know what I like.
I don't give a fuck like that.
Very few people really don't.
And even once we get to that point,
where is the one area?
A couple areas I should say.
Well,
we make those exceptions obviously.
Yes.
What else?
He breaks you.
Policy Ruins the mind,
the brakes.
Oh,
plus you just tragic.
It can break a man.
Plus he was one of my song and listen to
uh,
a from every time I died I got this
great lyric.
It says,
uh,
it's uh,
it's not lack of ambition that keeps
women not lack of ambition that keeps
good men bedridden.
It's true.
Yeah.
I know dudes that it becomes a,
it becomes such a massive part of their
life that eclipses all else.
I have a friend that I've,
I've seen him like glue do his fucking
phone and it's almost,
it should be integrated into his body.
He is on it so much and yet it's
constantly chattered little text here
there.
Oh well,
you know an hour's gone by on this one,
so I need to resend a response there and
just constant communication between
women the whole time because that's the
amount of effort it takes to to bang
that much fucking tail.
And I remember sitting there thinking,
I don't have the patience for this at
all.
Like it'll just get to a certain point.
Then if I deal with enough stupid shit,
I'm like,
you're a fucking idiot.
Get off of my fucking phone.
Who's my number?
I don't want to talk to you anymore.
It's hard enough for me to even have a
conversation with you with my thumbs,
let alone have to think about the idea
of putting aside a block of time to run
into you to work you up to the point of
trying just to have sex with you.
Oh yeah.
It gets to a weird point where some
people just want to chat all day.
What's up?
Like you get a text like what's up?
Nothing.
Some of you thinking of going to the
gym.
Fucking go fucking go,
cut.
Tell me how it turns out.
I,
you know,
that's what your facebook is for you to
tell me that you're going to go to the
gym telling me that you,
uh,
how,
how good of a workout you had you to
beat up with a face to face and go,
listen,
time is very precious for me.
My Vagina,
vagina,
man.
It does it.
So it takes a certain amount of.
And this is probably why I'm a single
man,
but uh,
also.
But that's also why men try so hard to
be bad motherfuckers.
They try so hard to be bad
motherfuckers.
Partially.
One of the reasons to dominate is to be
more attractive to women.
Yes,
natural.
But I got to tell you,
the difference between being a real bad
motherfucker and being an outwardly,
seemingly bad motherfucker is night and
day.
If you're an outwardly,
if you seem like you're a bad
motherfucker,
then people think than most people think
you are right.
The real bad motherfuckers.
Nobody really ever knows it and they
don't.
They don't have to tell the world,
they don't have to.
It's like someone who asked me the other
day about if I ever get into street
fights or anything like that.
And I go,
no,
because the people that even when I want
to fight them,
they won't.
And they're like,
oh,
well they all,
who would fight you?
And I go,
they don't know who I am.
I'm not famous.
I'm not a celebrity.
They don't know our,
amongst martial artists.
Right.
And you know,
if I,
if you give me my little pocket of
people,
yeah,
I'm fucking somebody there.
But in general you're here.
I'm sure dog on.
I'm so popular.
I'm so amazingly.
I'm just all flammable.
But the rest of the world,
nobody knows who the fuck I am.
I'm okay with that.
So,
you know,
I've had guys,
I balled me,
whatever I've seen the fucking the signs
of it.
You think if anybody knows when the
fight gonna happen and be a fighter.
So when I go,
or if someone's being a Dick
deliberately in my presence or to a
woman that's,
that's around or whatever,
and I step up and I say something like,
I go,
people don't want to fight me and I owe
because you're bigger.
No,
no.
It's got nothing to do any of that.
Because when you look into somebody's
eyes,
you can tell who really wants to fucking
fuck people up.
Who really doesn't.
And I don't get upset.
I don't yell,
I don't scream.
I don't have any,
I don't have to do any of that.
I just look at them.
I tell them how it's going to be and I
let him know if this is what we want to
do.
Like I'll enjoy it.
Like,
let's just please make this happen.
I've said the one guy,
I'm like,
how many friends do you got?
He was like,
why?
Because you don't have enough.
Let me just tell you that much.
Or I told one dude or do you don't know
anybody that knows anybody that knows
anybody that knows anybody that kicked
my ass.
I don't know what you're going to do
here.
But getting a bad way,
I laughed at a guy to anthrax,
I'm standing there with a girl and he
keeps trying to nudge.
People keep trying to manage through
right where we're at and I'm like,
of all places you see a dude and a chick
go somewhere else.
So I'm standing right there and I
decided that's it.
They're going to have to start going
around.
So I keep my elbows out,
tries.
I feel as dude bumping into me on the
rise,
I can't get through and he tries to get
thrown the left,
but I'm just standing tall so he's
trying to get around it.
But he can't.
It's like pushing him over him running
himself into my own elbow.
And then he starts getting mad.
I'm just,
he's yelling at me about something.
I'm going,
what is trying to get through man?
And he goes,
I saw,
I saw this,
that.
And I said,
can I go?
Anthrax is playing.
I can't fucking hear what you're saying.
And he's looking at me crazy.
I go,
just walk up to the front and he gets
all fucking wild eyed and he's looking
at me crazy and I go,
is this what you want to do?
Yeah.
I just started laughing at him.
I go,
you just need to keep moving,
and eventually the girl in front reaches
up and grabs a hold of his arm,
pulls down and go,
don't do this,
don't do this.
I'm just smiling the whole time and he
just fucking.
Of course he leaves.
It's all about the posture and you get
upset.
When I look at you,
you're,
you ready?
Recurring this in your mind.
You're recreating this in your mind.
I can see your pulse.
Quicken your testosterone that I stay
calm but carry a grudge.
You carry your story.
So I'm a Scorpio,
so apparently according to all the books
that are out there,
I.
Yeah,
cary grow,
but it's also.
It's total stripper talk.
Yeah,
it is.
I'm a Scorpio.
Spicy thing is a.
I love being in those violent
confrontations.
Why do you like that?
Is it because when you were picked on
when you were a kid,
you still harbor some resentment?
Towards people that we fuck with you
because you're a nice guy.
You would never fuck with anybody,
but if someone was fucking with you,
it's almost like now you have a license
to.
Yeah.
I can't put a finger on it.
It was,
I knew that,
uh,
I enjoyed fighting when I was a kid.
Like being in the fights.
I didn't start the fight,
but if you gave me a reason,
cool.
And then my mom said I was the angriest
kid ever.
She said,
well,
when I was born I came out frowning.
I looked like I looked like Ron Paul and
I fucking,
she
tried to hug me and I stiff armed her
area and she said,
broker fucking art.
I got the.
I wouldn't let my own mother holding me.
Wow.
And I was yellow and jaundiced and I was
an asshole apparently.
I just came out.
I was like,
and she said,
as a kid I just,
I would,
once I blew up about if I got angry,
I got so angry.
It wasn't like a temper Tantrum,
angry.
It was like,
phew.
Ming-Li raging violent,
like flames,
daggers.
I'm just,
that's connected between your health at
birth,
you know,
being in poor health at birth and being
brought into this world in a bad
situation where you're uncomfortable.
Yellow and jaundiced.
I wonder if that like set the stage for
an angry or maybe you got some viking
jeans.
I might got some Viking genes in there.
Even if I bought those,
I bought those at Nordstrom.
True Religion,
Viking jeans,
chuck notice gusset horns and a beard on
the crotch.
As long as it has plenty of like really
big buttons.
Snaps.
Intricately carved a place to hang my
hat,
my hands.
It has to be pre damaged.
Pretty damning.
Of course it has to look like it's
already been through.
You know,
the Poetic Edda.
That's the only thing that's almost as
gay as the sagging pants is the caught
up pants.
The chopped up.
The stress is that I went to one place
and I was like,
do you have any fucking pants?
Don't have holes in them.
Can I just buy a pair of.
I like to have a regular pair of jeans.
I'm not a child.
Sorry.
This is not.
This is not gonna last,
this fake worn out jeans.
This shit is temporary and I'm not
buying a fucking pair of jeans that are
fake,
worn out.
It's one thing you wear a pair of jeans
out.
There's pride in that because these are
jeans I've had for 10 fucking years.
They're comfortable is shit.
Yeah,
there's some holes in them,
but I broke them in man.
I think so and so in those days.
There you go.
I don't know if I have any.
I want to actually take that DNA test
that tells you why they can tell you if.
Because I know I'm German and I know I'm
Irish and Cherokee Indian and I brought
some English in me,
but no,
I got Indiana toll on me.
I know I do.
This brow Ridge fucking brother in law
used to call me the,
uh,
the eagle from the muppets,
the muppets and I never even thought
about the eagle is such a prominent
frown asshole path.
That's a funny fucker.
But I want to take that test to also see
if I got the warrior gene.
Oh yeah.
There is a warranty supposed to make.
Make
People Kinda gnarly and,
and the thing is like,
I don't have to have anything personal
or any girls.
I don't to get into a fight,
but I enjoyed it.
I even getting hit hitting back like
just the whole thing.
I know for me fighting is a time I feel
most alive and free in the entire world
because I can go out there and do just
about anything I can do with who I am
and no one's going to try and stop me.
Do you prefer
I'm old school rules rules?
I prefer for those who don't know,
super raw was soccer kids.
Stomps.
Had I prefer headbutts elbows?
No.
No,
I understand.
No gloves.
Our gloves,
they were,
I think they were gloves.
Do you prefer gloves or no gloves.
I prefer gloves only for your own kind
of fit but uh,
or broken hands.
But uh,
not to say that it's really been doing
much shinier hand wrote this.
He's got a broken leg.
A lot of broken hands.
Nma.
Yeah.
Uh,
but a super common,
right?
Yeah.
Very.
Is there any way around that?
It's hard to say.
I don't know if it's an equipment thing.
Is it possible to pad the gloves more or
is it just that one thing I noticed and
pride,
there wasn't that many broken hands.
Yeah,
well I was asking that once too,
and I was saying,
is it a better glove?
Is a pride glove,
a thicker glove?
Uh,
not necessarily son I would say because
it's all fixed fights.
Oh,
of course.
Say that he's so crazy.
Well,
he said some of that shed about like the
like pride fights.
Like,
come on man,
you know,
some of that is just,
it's brilliant stance to take.
It's such a,
it's such a fucking aggressive,
just obnoxious thing to say someone is
bound to get run now who's done or the
person that gets mad at the person who
says it,
person gets mad
of course.
But the problem is there's a wee bit a
truth in the fact that some fights in
pride.
We're staged.
So like if you look at Coleman Takata,
it's pretty obvious or something going
on there.
There's a few every now and that.
I mean,
you look at like a cro cop,
Nogueira.
That's a real fucking fight.
There's no doubt about it.
That's a real fucking fine.
But man,
you watched Coleman tap out to that heel
hooks from Chicago.
Wait a minute.
Oh,
I mean it was ridiculous.
It's not the best example of pride.
What was it like being.
You were there in the golden era,
man.
I mean you were there during the time
when pride was,
in my opinion,
like put on some of the greatest shows
in mixed martial arts history to pride,
openlink Grand Prix,
the middleweight Grand Prix.
I mean you just look at just the
historic fights like minute Toro versus
Bob Sapp.
I mean there was some crazy historic
fights from your era.
That was a.
You were there,
man.
You were there for all that shit.
What was that like?
Unfucking believable dude was like
performing for was the biggest crowd you
did a biggest crowd ever fought in front
of was $50,000.
The biggest.
The biggest crowd I ever stepped out in
front of them at least grabbed the mic,
was 93.
Jesus to want to tell you how big it is
here and I go,
it is,
and in America it's once it hits the
media,
the way American media is,
things blow up in such a different
capacity than they do in Japan,
but man,
we were stepping in front of $30,000
on a regular basis.
I did a show with Hulk Hogan,
you know,
Hulk Hogan wrestling shown on 55,000
people and I fought a,
you know,
she thought,
Gosh,
independent my king of pancreas in the
Tokyo Dome.
That's.
It doesn't.
Those shows were on such a different
level than what we see here in the
states and the feeling of course feeling
is going to be different in terms of the
culturally it's going to be way
different because you have Japan,
this incredible homogeneous society with
their ways and very specific versus
America.
So trying to compare that sort of thing
is not really fair.
Apples and oranges really is.
People are different everywhere you go
hold those fights in Uganda or you hold
them in Transylvania or what.
They're always going to be different
because people's cultures are different.
A plaid,
they felt so dynamic.
Those shows,
they were so big,
it wasn't just the lights and that was
the mood,
the setting.
When that music would start up and the
lights would drop,
don't,
and you're sitting in back and I'm
fighting like ninth or something,
but I'm all of a sudden I'm just wired,
I'm ready to go.
I'm like,
let's just fucking grab swords and start
screaming and running down the ramp.
A lot of pageantry to those events too.
I mean,
look,
I did not appreciate it sometimes when I
was like,
just get into the fucking fights
already,
like six hours long and you like to be
so jazzed up in the beginning,
but looking back,
man,
when everybody would line up,
you know,
when they would introduce fighters one
at a time and they would all line up,
you're like,
wow,
this is going to be a fucking epic
night.
It really did build it up and it really
did make it more of a special event.
You know?
I mean,
the UFC,
they've kind of done away with even some
of the walk ins,
like,
well,
we're pressed for time.
Sometimes guys are already in the cage
and there's no walking at all.
It doesn't even have walked in.
Uh,
I,
you know,
a TV product definitely changes things
and in Japan they're TV system is way
different than they,
than we run out.
Joel,
he'll deal over.
I'll get burned.
Yeah.
He,
uh,
he was a big fan of Michael Jackson's
and he thought it would be real cool
to set himself on fire before he went
out and fought.
Not what Jerry curl before he lit up.
Oh,
Jerry curl has another thing that ever
happened.
And Pre ripped jeans.
How the fuck did those exist?
He'll got hit with.
He was in the wrong spot.
I don't know if the marker was wrong or
he lost in translation and he got hit
with some pyrotechnics and it just lit
him up.
Now.
Thankfully he,
you know,
with the burns,
he was able to,
to come back and he even fought again in
pride.
Um,
and so I'm really,
really glad that,
that,
that was the case because you'll hear
the Olivia and luke delivery legend
school nhb dude at that.
That's.
Yeah.
Sad
though.
It's sad.
I mean,
for a lot of people don't know.
He was one of the original guys back in
the day,
you know,
he fought in some of those,
uh,
those,
valley to two events,
the bare knuckle,
no rules,
events there were so crazy.
Like when Gary Goodrich fought that
Pedro grabbed this deck and they really
reached into his pants,
there was no rule against it.
So reach into his pants and crushed his
balls and his dick in his hand like no
one had ever thought of that.
No one had ever.
But Gary went so deep,
he literally grabbed the guy showed
deep.
Oh,
Gary Good.
Which is a fucking arm wrestling
champion with these gigantic arms.
And just imagine that that guy crushing
your package.
I think he might've started off with the
tickle just to let go the underlings.
And if tickle turned into a squeeze and
see the guide,
the guy didn't tap out immediately.
It wasn't like saying giant black man
hand in my crotch screaming,
fuck no.
Yeah.
Finger and uh,
you know,
he was giving me a shocker.
Prostate balls were already numb.
It's like he had taken so many.
That's why.
That's why he tapped out as Gary's.
He's like knuckles deep and he's like,
he's got two knuckles in there and he's
going,
you know what to do.
Do you need to go get this
st if you know we're fighting a lot,
we need to get you out of here.
And he's like,
thanks.
Thank you so much.
Did,
did you ever put a fight in A.
I never stuck my nipples in a man's ass.
Any event that allowed ball shots,
like the old he attacked me,
Joseph,
you know,
by the,
by the time we were doing that,
it was,
you always sort of a universal like,
dude,
don't just,
don't hit anybody in the nuts.
Joe Simons a famous moment in mma
boom,
and he's like a tiger choke on it.
Especially when you,
you know,
find out later that you know,
joe is a fucking mass rapists and
maniacs,
crazy person,
crazy person who was involved in a gang
rape,
you know,
they caught him for something else and
they did a DNA scan on him.
That guy used to always hang around the
comedy store.
He was always in the back room and the
comments that you'd run into him and he
call everyone sir and like bout
everyone.
He was really weird.
It was really weird.
Yeah.
And he have like no shirt on and he was
like super yolked.
Really short limbs but super.
Yeah.
You'd be calling everyone now
this guy was like a mass or a gang
rapists.
You're like,
Oh wow,
what a weird guy to have hanging around
about as bad as it can be,
but I don't know.
I would think that I would.
I think he,
in his mind he probably said his bar
even higher than that.
Did you ever try any of these
compression shorts?
A Cup?
Things like videos of them,
like shockoe has one and diamond mma
have one.
You know,
I used to wear the 30 bucks everyone
tour,
but I also learned a hard lesson of if
you're wearing.
I see,
okay.
I also,
I worry about like Tito trunks,
right?
So if you're wearing spandex trunks and
you put spandex shorts on underneath
that spandex and Spandex,
just sort of all of a sudden your outer
trunks are turned into some sort of
daisy Duke Wedgie up your ass and then
you're under trunks are hanging.
He just looked like a fun,
sexy as shit.
He was like,
oh my God,
look at that little.
Those compression shorts is probably the
best way to avoid a really bad ball
shots where I keep it in place.
Or is it a trap or Die Cup?
I think if you use Taco jockstrap just
trap with,
uh,
with uh,
with one of those flexible cups because
my,
my thighs are so big that a normal cup,
I just,
it just starts digging into the inside
of my legs.
Those flexible cups are good.
But these,
uh,
I've,
I've tried recently.
The reason why I asked this is a diamond
nma has this really intense compression
shorts setup with all of these straps
and his videos,
like are you sure it's for training and
not for like,
well,
it's got a ball gag,
but it's optional.
The uh,
the idea is that this guy has eliminated
the movement,
which is where the cup fails.
You know,
the cup moves to the side and then you
get kicked in the balls and the cup
actually hits the balls,
which obviously can happen if you just
have a loose jock strap to the side.
Yeah.
His shit is.
Yeah,
there's no tuskie's from the side.
This shit is slammed in place,
but Kenny Florian says that a Thai Cup
is the best.
He says that you could if you.
It's uncomfortable as fuck because it
has to go up your ass like a g string.
But if you do it that way,
it's not moving.
It's just sort of saying Kenny Florian
isn't the mass play.
I don't think he's into that man.
I don't think he minds shaped inner
thighs though.
Steel Cup,
like a little piece of leather around
rather than balm and do is grunt.
Yeah,
you'd probably have to.
Before you get going,
you'll probably have to use some key and
the size of your thighs a little bit.
Kaggle's.
Okay.
They can hear it.
So here we're going off in the
direction.
We're talking a lot about cups.
Yeah.
Which is not entirely what I thought it
was going to be on the table today,
but it's a terrible design.
The human body with the balls and the
outside fighting.
I mean we,
you,
you're a fighter,
but if your involvement on the outside
she couldn't like true lick them while
you're adding.
You're stroking it.
Yeah.
It's like a trade off.
I mean you gotta you got the good with
the bad on that.
What a ridiculous button that every man
has his button seeing.
Ding,
Ding.
It's out there.
Everybody knows where it is.
We're all running around vulnerable and
we've made countless jokes about it.
If you couldn't,
didn't know that it was not only with
the painful.
It's hilarious.
Yeah.
Even when you're watching an mma about
and uh,
someone to get kicked in the balls,
like,
oh,
one more time.
Yeah,
let's launch a few.
we always replay it.
I don't know why.
There's no reason to.
There's got to be fetishes built around
cups,
I'm sure.
Absolutely.
I'm sure people like someone that
where's the cup and gets a boner under
the cup somehow.
I don't know.
It's like crushing is mushroom were
dudes that like jerking off to guys.
Joseph,
I heard your podcast.
Joseph wasn't funny.
What were you send them to me.
He should.
He shouldn't really tell this story,
but he was focusing on former UFC
heavyweight champion,
great,
great kickboxer world kickboxing
champion and trained in honor of a
utility bill.
Not a joke.
So he's got this leather utility belt
thing with pockets and pouches and all
this shit and gadgets as monogrammed on
it for multiple sclerosis.
So it's not quite a fanny pack.
Oh,
it is the ultimate of fanny packs.
It's Batman utility belt.
I'm a little jealous.
Well,
he can get one made for you.
I mean,
he was pretty proud to tell me about
where I'm like,
I am actually mocking you.
I'm not,
I'm not asking for free for,
for location on where I could have one
of my own.
You saw,
I'm sure you saw Maurice,
his last fight.
Of course I did.
I jumped out of my chair.
I was losing my shit.
It was so awesome.
And I,
I know exactly when it was all going to
go down hill.
There was a point because I used to spar
and race all the time and he's standing
out in front of the guy and he kinda
gets this little grin.
I go,
that's it.
He's figured this dude out.
He's got them handled.
This only going to get worse from here
and the more mode doesn't go for the
kill.
He's not like a get in there and just
trying to annihilate you.
Do he chopped you just score.
Score.
Job Too hard.
It's too hard to score.
Score.
That's Maury Smith.
So,
um,
so anyway,
so he's,
he's fighting say score,
score,
score score.
If you,
if you keep landing you're good.
But you know,
eventually I'll try to go for the kill.
You set yourself up and you know,
eventually,
yes.
Eventually the right shop will present
itself.
So you know the,
he threw that right hand and step right
kick.
He knew the guy was going to take off to
his left and the aid it and it was,
oh his majesty.
He was great in the first Coleman fight,
man,
whether when you really got a chance to
see talk all that shit.
He's like,
oh,
you hit like a girl and all this.
And Coleman tried to punch them out and
gassed and he just took his phone and he
never got upset by it.
All I was,
I was talking to,
me and him were talking before the fight
and everybody thought he was going to
his death and Maurice was,
he was so calm.
He was just hanging out back there with
kirk the duties to train them and to
transcend the mind.
Settle down.
Marie Smith,
he's driving around in his porsche
kickboxer old like read,
done.
He always had like 73 was like a little
too much engine.
The GTT kid on it or something.
So anyways,
he's driving around this porsche and I
think somebody,
he,
I don't remember how he ended up getting
contact with us.
He was fighting,
he was doing an extreme fighting and
then he fight in UFC and this guy at a
bus stop somehow he said,
and he goes,
Hey,
I want to buy something off of you.
And Maria says like,
okay,
he's like anybody with jock strap.
Emory's had his stuff on him and he goes
like 300 bucks,
documenter bucks takes off and is like,
you can do whatever he wants.
What an idiot,
you know,
I ain't got $300.
And you have now a Maurice Smith limited
edition semen stained fricking jockstrap
now like maybe the guys wearing it on
his face,
like darth vader,
like it's something but something.
And then it made me think,
what is my jock strapless?
What I sell it.
Fuck yeah.
How much
I'd like to get five fingers.
Four fingers,
thousand bucks.
That's not impossible.
You know what I think if you could take,
well it's too bad.
You probably already watched it from the
great man.
You know what?
It'd be amazing plastic bags.
I'm not saying you should fake this,
but if you did have plastic bags where
you structure your shock from the randy
couture fight is in a Ziploc bag for
medically sealed medically seal.
This is the jock strap you were wearing
when you won the title straps.
Yeah.
Only jockstraps.
Good.
If you just had them all in a file at
home.
I'm not saying you should fake this,
but if you did have like a file that you
pull apart and it was filled with
organized.
How many fights have you had?
No.
Fuck a unsanctioned.
Okay.
Included over 50.
Could you imagine if you had 50 plastic
bags filled with every jockstrap from
every fight he'd ever been in,
including some blood on him,
some smeared,
you know,
some with quick knockouts where you
didn't even really get.
I'm stinky.
They would have to be hermetically seal
because of the smell is a radiator shops
for,
for like a 50 mile radius of pulling
every woman and every feral dog.
Shit.
Coyotes at night.
And uh,
the like the MBA one would probably be
worth the most because there's still
like sweat inside the bag.
Something like bubbles,
some moisture bubbles in the bag,
you know,
we're like,
yeah,
go back to the pride days.
Those are dried out right now.
They've shrunk a little event.
That would be somebody like,
someone's going to do it now because we
brought it up.
We set that in motion.
This is going to be sold.
I got to pay for tires if I keep blowing
up.
So what better than to use a little bit
of a laugh around my waist might be able
to retire on this.
I'm telling you,
if you could just stop,
you could,
you would,
you could retire on something as
ridiculous as that sounds.
The jocks job.
Well,
we should put up a thing.
You got one more fight coming up in
strikeforce,
right?
Yeah.
When,
how long has he been going to be before
your hands healed?
Uh,
I'm sure I got at least another three
months.
What do you have to do for like physical
therapy when that happens?
Did they put a pin in it?
And everything,
I'm going to have that removed at some
point.
Basically you have to have that removed
or is it an option?
No,
I don't have to,
but I think it's smarter in the long run
to heal the stronger.
That way a lot of people don't have
plates in there on the plate is the
problem.
Right.
And if it does break,
if you break the hardware and that ain't
got that crap stuck in the bone,
it makes it even worse.
Put it all back together.
What's a Nogueira situation like this?
I think it's called a humorous.
The upper bone snapped when a mere
tapped him.
I think he just started rubbing off on
it.
They,
uh,
his issue right now is the plane,
you know,
I don't know if they can go in and take
it out though.
Is it every fight?
No,
he pulled out of the Congo fine.
He can,
uh,
he apparently is in intense pain during
wrestling when he was fine for a little
while.
But then when it got to wrestling,
it was just too much pain,
I guess,
that that plate,
digging into your bones and digging into
the army,
I don't think you're supposed to.
I mean,
I think that has to be probably removed
if you're gonna engage in sports.
What about um,
uh,
mirrors,
leg,
whatever happened with that.
Does he still have the plate?
And then I probably the prosthetic with
a machine gun and so great hides his
knives.
He's still crazy,
strongest dudes walking the planet and
I'm covered in weapons,
convert it.
God,
all the people that want to attack me.
Well,
I don't know what that's all about,
but he is the wrong dude to fuck.
Yeah.
No.
You know what,
if he fell down a flight of stairs,
he stabbed and stuff to death and shoot
people.
Yeah.
Got Two office buildings.
Trips on the sidewalk.
Ankle gun goes off.
Oh,
is the gas station across the street is
dictate or just stats?
Yeah.
What's up with him?
I was like,
who's already a killer?
And he wants to be like fully armed to
the teeth when he leaves her house,
he's like a real survivalist type.
The
dude and that way you live in Vegas.
I imagine his survival skills are a lot
different than the usual guy.
Like how do you avoid vomit on the
street?
And I didn't get into the Strip club
without paying.
When you work there,
it's easy.
But what?
Vegas is a dark place though as far as
like Vegas.
I'm like,
I hate Vegas.
I don't like it because it's one,
it's,
it's purposefully fake an engineered to
fuck you up.
Like even from the carpet from the way
they did.
I think it's kind of cool that they
figured out the ways to make you gamble
and spend money and fuck your life over
to a scientist.
Some formula like wow,
that's pretty good.
That's fucking cool.
In a way,
I just don't want it to happen to me.
But then once you leave the strip,
right?
Leave all the opulence and all the cool
shit that they're there,
all the fucking things that they're
dangling out there to pull you in and
you get just outside the strip.
Like every service industry thing around
there is filled full of all the last
great tea.
Fucking prison,
tatted,
like wrangled up,
fucking used condoms.
Have people that,
that all like lost everything in Vegas
and they can't leave and
you know,
you go and you order your,
your sonic burger and you're like,
fuck dude,
I don't know what happened to you,
but I that looks contagious and I don't
really like,
you know,
seven like fucking snaggle tooth on one
side.
It's a strange,
strange part of the news.
Strange part of the country.
Desert,
desert.
What is it?
A desert miss?
There's life in the desert.
I've seen on that national geographic
bullshit too.
I know it,
but not really meant for us.
Yeah.
You know who lives in the desert?
Crazy people.
Chromogens are Weirdos.
We were actually talking about that
before you got here were like the shit
goes down.
Vegas is one of the last places you want
to be because there's no food there.
They can't get food,
so once the truck stopped coming in and
playing stop landing with food,
$6,
prime ribs gone,
all that shit.
Yeah,
no money.
There's no money for casinos.
Said northwest.
You can grow everything you need up
there.
That's the truth.
I was watching the video.
Chael sonnen preparing for Anderson
Silva and it showed Portland.
I'm like,
God damn,
that's beautiful.
Go fucking green.
Everything is green and healthy.
I mean,
you could have an incredible car.
You'd have a serious problem.
Portland,
why all the people with the fucking
disks in their ears?
You'd be.
You'd be off.
Put all the other sizes.
Not Sagging yet.
I know.
That's another thing.
I don't get the bullring so many
beautiful women have that.
It's just like it should only be okay if
you can attach a little chain onto it
and drag them around.
What's that?
A girl or Tina Marie,
didn't she?
She had the nose like this thing go into
the war to the ear,
right number,
yeah.
Portland does have a lot of freaky
people with those nose rings.
That nose ring is so unnecessary.
I've seen some girls nose ring and it's
kind of sexy,
like I did it a girl once you had a ring
in or not.
People can pull shit off,
but they can't pull off that bull ring.
That's pretty.
I've never seen anybody.
The other thing is chest tattoos on a
woman is not my thing.
Unless she's hot as fuck.
I was so goal with the wings and I look
at it,
but I'm like,
you're not a sailor apa fight or
something like,
no,
you're not.
So you don't know what you have tits.
You have the greatest tattoo ever
created for your chest.
Yeah,
the ultimate big fish,
little tits,
whatever.
You got kids.
You don't need to put ink on top of the
tits.
Leave the tits alone.
Yeah,
it's.
Leave me to have the chest tattoos and
the handlebar mustaches.
It's why you brought this up.
I have to write something down because I
can't forget that.
Uh,
I have to make fun of my friend Bill
Burr for using,
uh,
a Thomas Guide in 2012.
One of those dudes like,
he,
uh,
I loved the guys and awesome comedian,
but he has a 1950 a,
a pickup,
I think it's got like the shifter on the
column on the column and he got no
navigation system.
He uses fucking Thomas Guides and he's
like,
he's always joking around about it,
you know,
like using Thomas Guides know there's
some people that refuse map.
They get it,
they get a kick out of like ignoring
antiquated to the level of difficulty.
Yeah.
You know,
why people have maps because it was
fucking hard trying to fucking follow
the Falcon as it went down the road.
And remember.
No.
So we created a map and I ain't went
from a map.
And this is your bed,
I think actually about the whole,
you know,
and now you're going to go back to when
you were living in some fucking dirt
hole when you discovered you had a
bathtub.
Right.
Look at how much of an advancement type.
This is wonderful.
I'm gonna.
Have my baby in a bathtub and then you
go from that and you have a hospital and
then now all of a sudden like,
no,
let's go back into a fucking hole full
of mud and have a baby in that because
that's natural.
Yeah.
Well that was me making fun of women
want to have natural births like stupid
somebody else.
Yeah,
no,
I've heard that.
Oh,
that's his.
Well,
it becomes a thing man.
When you are around a bunch of people,
you kind of forget sometimes.
Who was the one who said it,
but it made the.
It's funny,
but it makes perfect sense.
Like it's not,
there's nothing.
Okay.
Having wine.
I have a natural childbirth in some way
or whatever.
Like okay,
I can.
All right.
Yeah.
I get it on a beat where the WHO has the
most likely chance.
Exactly.
Died constantly all the time.
So now we have the ability to keep
babies from dying.
So why don't we do that?
So it's the same thing.
Like,
okay,
I understand using a thomas map or
whatever,
but that.
Sorry,
we have gps now and now if you have the
Thomas guys because you're in case your
gps fails,
that's cool.
Kids driving a three speed truck.
That's all right too.
Like that's
as long as you're aware of what you're
dealing with.
You're okay.
I just drove up here in [inaudible] 69
while barely drove up here in
[inaudible].
60 nine oldsmobile,
but I know what I'm dealing with and I'm
okay with that,
but I didn't drive up here with a
fucking thomas map the whole time trying
to do this.
I used to have a 68,
four,
two.
Used to have a lot of cool shit.
I love that.
So do I bet back that back bumper and
one of the greatest bumpers in the
history of automobiles,
that giant chrome shying bumper.
That's one of the reasons why I have
this kind of car because I had a 300 CSR
t a great car.
It had been rear ended twice,
so I never got any wrecks until I got to
California.
I'm on the six.
Oh five.
We get past this,
this fucked up traffic and I start
driving by and I see it fucked up car on
the right,
which is why we're also,
I'm like,
fucking California,
you just can't go a day without having
to run yourself into somebody else,
like just fucking morons.
And we speed up and then started slowing
down and I'm like,
ah,
fuck.
I slow down,
stop and then right into my back.
Wasn't paying attention,
of course not.
And then they manage it,
fixed the car from that.
It's all good.
I go and I pull the trim off,
have all the chrome turned black and do
all that and make the murder of the car
looks awesome.
Okay,
cool.
I'm going to keep onto this for so many
more years and then I'll finally get a
new car and then I'm leaving at this
place like 2:30
in the morning.
It's been a good night for.
And I'm on beverly and last Deanna.
I just parked for four cars maybe ahead
of me.
Is that a red light?
And I'm just chilling,
like didn't even hit brakes.
There's a ranger just plowed right into
the back.
I mean,
you just annihilates the back of my car.
Was He texting?
I don't know what he was doing.
He wasn't drunk because the first thing
I did is I got hit and at first I
thought,
Oh shit.
It was a crazy boyfriend.
Hit me like crazy ex boyfriend.
Sorry.
No,
it's not that guy.
Uh,
and his truck and I looked over and so I
see,
I see.
I see a truck and I got.
Well the first thing is doing all this
fighting shit that I've been doing high
stress situations.
I know I have way better facilities than
your average person.
Even today I'm driving in the
fascinating 75 miles an hour and there's
that wall on the one tab on the left
hand side of the concrete divider and I
heard boom.
And it goes out and the car immediately
tries to go into the wall.
But I manage that by breaking the car.
Um,
I'm applying brakes and feathering it
and steering the wheel and keeping it
straight.
I didn't hit a fucking thing,
you know?
Oh yeah,
like a man,
Josh Barnett,
that once I wrote that ditch and I
fucked it,
looked good and then ate it and then it.
And then I became buffered and more
sexually dominant.
My prowess,
my sperm count went up so long.
We've been doing this almost two hours,
an hour,
45.
So I go and I get hit.
Look,
I see the truck,
first thing I do when to get out of the
car and I jog over to where the truck is
pulled over onto the side.
And then I noticed different truck come
over,
take a look,
and I see these two dudes in the car and
they're like freaking out.
Like,
oh my God,
fuck,
I can't believe I just did.
I can't believe this.
They're upset about getting into an
accident.
Not Drunk at all.
So we texted each other,
even one of the two,
maybe both at the same time,
texting while blown each other,
texting you about how good it felt to be
blown away.
It's just so awesome.
Uh,
so after that I'm like,
you know what?
I really liked the idea of having a nice
allsteel car,
so like,
go ahead and run into this.
See how that's gonna work out for you.
That's true.
That's one thing about those old cars,
man.
Naked.
Take a fucking hell of a wallop.
You can smash into stuff and you know,
when I finally lose it and I just
started going Berserk on the freeway and
hitting people,
then this is going to be the vehicle to
do it.
It's definitely better than like a
prius.
Oh,
everything's better than,
than a fucking Prius.
I assault you seen windows on the road
tax.
They're the worst because they can't
even fit any luggage in the trunk
headache.
But I'm,
I don't have anything against hybrid
technologies or cleaner,
safer burning stuff.
Fine.
Cool.
With the rumble of the V eight.
No,
no you can't.
And,
and here's the thing,
like if you want to drive that,
go for it.
You think you're saving the environment
by creating a bunch of fucking shitty
batteries that are going to pollute
something somewhere.
Then all whatever minerals from Congo.
So,
uh,
anything designed that it's all a
fucking scam.
It's not,
there's,
there's been ways I'm sure that you
could have the most fuel efficient
gasoline powered car that we have no
idea because every one of those things
has been shelved on purpose by the oil
companies themselves because what good
would it do to you to have to buy less
gas is probably a car that can run on
water running.
So anyhow,
uh,
etc.
These prius's and it's okay,
but it has no soul hybrid cars have no
souls whatsoever.
I've driven a hybrid car and I'm like,
well,
you know,
iT drives,
it's a car,
it's fine and does what it means to do,
but I feel like I'm in a soulless,
lifeless box and you sPend so much time,
especially if you live in la behind the
wheel.
I want to drive something that makes me
feel good about being in it.
That makes me get out of bed in the
morning and go to get my car and be
like,
god damn,
if you were a chick I totally hit on,
you know,
and that's a 69 old does that.
Well it's a grizzled girl,
I'll tell you that.
But she knows her way around the block a
no,
she,
she smoked a about 687,000
cigarettes in her life and you know,
now she's,
she talks with some of those little
fucking microphone dailies in her neck,
but it's,
you know,
it's got personality and the car is not
perfect and that's fine.
You know,
it's mechanically sound and it runs
great and it's fun.
And trying to explain the appeal though.
It's of like one of those having like a
v eight engine.
It has.
You turn the car over and it's got a
sound.
It's like,
hey,
what's up here?
Are you doing?
Where are we?
What are we doing today?
What do you want to do?
My run some shit over.
I want to go fast.
What do you want to do now?
We could just hang out,
just fucking get on the road.
It's completely different experience
that corolla,
even though corollas and french car come
get you where you want to go.
It's lacking that and this something
that was captured in the creation of
those cars.
These cars are steel and they're solid.
They're meant to last a very long time.
They are and there are touches in terms
of comfort and of just style that are so
stupid like you didn't.
That's obnoxious.
The you didn't have to create little
emblems if some little fucker had to
paint himself and then put them on the
inside of the interior like no one's
ever going to pay attention to half of
that shit,
but they did it anyways,
you know,
and they're like sinking the lights in
in a certain way and having to put
chrome around that bezel and going the
extra mile,
the extra 30 of mile that is,
you're not gonna get in a car nowadays
and be in that kind of.
It's like going into those old buildings
and seeing all those touches that they
put into the flooring,
into the mantles and you're getting
that.
But in a vehicle you can tell the
difference between factory just churning
out some,
you know,
four wheeled immobile to get you
wherever and somebody even a,
a factory line where people are putting
these things together.
Do you appreciate a technologically
advanced cars?
Like,
like a nissan gtr
bruised in the godzilla.
Yeah.
I think it's amazing that they can make
over 4,000
pound car run that fast.
I don't think it's quite that heavy.
I think it's 3,930
8:50.
It's heavy.
It's very heavy.
Four wheel drive,
zero to 60 in less than three seconds.
It's crazy.
It's unreal or their car and then it'll
do it.
And in such a way that what my race or
friends will telling me that almost any
idiot can get behind the wheel of that
car and learned to be fast.
So I in fact in.
So some folks were like,
don't get one of those.
I'm,
well,
I'm like,
I'm not just sitting on a grant.
I'm going to go run out and buy a car
with,
but okay,
why not?
And I go,
you're not gonna you're going to get
bored.
You know,
it's going to be awesome.
It's going to this and that.
And then eventually it's like there's no
fun in this isn't it?
Doesn't need to be.
Well it doesn't scare the shit out of
you.
It doesn't come as everything.
Yeah,
it does everything and does it all well
and it takes all the,
the efforts and a lot of the skills out
of learning and adapting to a vehicle
and it takes it away.
Well,
you can take all that shit
off.
You can shut off all that shit.
You can shut off all that electronic
control and treated like you're on a
race track and then it'll scare the fuck
out of here.
You can go sideways on that car.
Oh,
I'm sure you can.
Yeah,
you just have to just shut off all those
stability system.
Right?
I love the car.
I think it's one of the coolest cars on
the road.
It's almost ridiculous to get anything
else.
If you wanted to get a car that goes
fast,
like that car,
not only is it go fast,
it's like it's super tech.
It's like the most advanced
technological achievement as far as like
what we can do today to get you to go
fast and safe.
That's the most efficient
a car that costs three times as much.
Right?
Yeah.
But then I,
you know,
I was talking to somebody about the
difference.
There's okay that gtr will do it,
but when you get in that gtr and you
look around and it is comfortable and
it's got everything you need or if you
get in that ferrari or that all of a
sudden things,
it's not okay.
The ferrari isn't maybe quite as fast or
maybe it's as fast,
but you look at the way it was put
together in a way to let it remain.
But hands.
I mean there's a huge difference there
and I would have trouble with a frog is
I would love to get behind the wheel,
which I've never done and drive the shit
out of one and treat it like,
like,
like that.
It is totally true.
She is all over.
Yeah.
But uh,
um,
it's too expensive.
You just,
you do that and all of a sudden the bill
shows up for changing oil breaks,
all that fun.
And if you don't have the,
the,
the nomenclature that says you had it
all done,
then the value starts going down and
like that's just too much fucking money.
Which is also why I bought a sIxty nine
olds cutlass.
That is not a super special one.
It's not super pretty.
It's not perfect.
So when it gets dinged,
oh well,
whatever.
Well,
that's one of the things I've always
said why there's something to be said
for like a corvette zr one.
It's like what they've done is just
blown everything out of the water as far
as performance.
As far as zero to 60,
it's right up there with every other car
that's ever been made.
Zero $60.
Zero stops quicker than any car that's
ever been made has got one of the most
ridiculous norberg ring times,
but it's like,
no,
the interior is friends.
Good,
but look.
Okay,
put all that shit aside.
The fuck it's or works right?
You hit that,
that gas pedal,
that's a real engine bitch.
That's a 638 horsepower va that.
That sounds like.
Like like hell.
It sounds like the fires of hell
world challenge a road racing for a,
for a scca.
They have a team of a cadillac and all
those fucking cts bees.
Those are ridiculous.
They start rolling around the crack.
They sound bad.
Fuck yeah.
They just,
they sound like even if they don't take
first,
they at least let everybody know that
they were there.
So beastly fucking car and if you,
those ctsv are ridiculous.
Like you can't believe you're in a four
door sedan that's a cadillac,
you know,
and they were like 560 something fucking
horsepower essentially the same engine.
It's a deep tuned version of the zr one
gesture and just hauling ass and you get
in a wagon so you just take your kids in
the back.
It shows the g force on a wagon.
We live in an awesome time as far as
what they're,
what's,
what's possible too.
I think so I think our cars have come to
such a different level.
I love my,
my gt $500 [inaudible].
It's such a bad ass car and my sponsors
and everybody have helped me to make it
even more gnarly.
Yeah.
I have a gt 500.
I have a 2011 convertible.
What do you think?
Fucking grave.
But he's just an amazing car.
It sounds so good.
You could slide the tail out if you want
to.
You know,
I mean it has some sort of traction
control,
but it's a fucking live actual car.
It's fun.
It's really enjoyable.
Yeah.
Well I went and took all that enjoyable
thing and then turned it into like a
murderer.
So why put a whipple supercharger on it?
So it's 686 horsepower.
I got kw and bmr for suspension.
They,
I braced the whole fucking thing up and
have coil overs all around.
And the wider tires.
Not yet,
but you're going to be.
Yeah,
no,
a hrd is supposed to make the wheels for
a,
for the car.
I'm just waiting on somebody to step on
the brakes because it's going to be in
the optimal ultimate streetcar
challenges.
Here I've got one piece,
carbon,
uh,
one piece of aluminum drive line from
lethal performance and like all this
different stuff.
And uh,
I had somebody drive the car,
I took the rear seats out of it.
I pulled all the rivers,
all the rear stuff out by this little
deal set in a.
I've got to put a roll cage in a,
uh,
honestly.
And I'm still taking weight out of the
car.
And doing the thing,
but it's still,
it's got the stereo in it,
it's got everything.
It's.
I put these amazing recaro seats in the
front.
Uh,
it's super comfy.
But,
and I've got this magnaflow exhaust all
through these three inch pipes and I,
every time I turned the car over,
I mean I know that my neighbors are just
like fucking rambling.
Just a stock exhaust and the gt fIve
fucking amazing.
Now.
It's ridiculous.
It's one of the greatest sounds ever
that the roar of a good va,
great exhaust.
And uh,
I let I let this guy drive it and he
goes,
it's cars trying to murder you.
I,
oh yeah.
Pretty much.
I tell everyone it's a 30 slash 30 car
in 30 seconds to 30 feet.
Some joe schmoe gets behind the wheel.
They've wrecked it because it'll just go
out from underneath you.
It doesn't take anything to blow the
tires on it.
Way too much power for those back tires.
Right?
Well,
kind of.
Well the suspension,
honestly,
leaving a belt optima challenge last
year.
It's just watching.
And I decided to go through death valley
instead of.
And then meet up with the 15 so it was
just stretches of just empty road and
I've got this little problem right now.
I've got to sort that out.
So I like to put the car in limp mode so
I can't stop it.
I can pull into stuff I pick,
it'll cruise at 140 flat as fuck.
And if you go into a 55 mile,
an hour corner at 1:20
and just rolls right through it and
comes right back out.
I mean this,
this suspension from kw and all the
chassis embracing shift from bmr just
has this thing rocked on the ground and
I took it to this guy out in west la.
And Then this guy,
tom can't remember the name of his shop,
but at any moment you could have like
$11 million with the cars all sitting
around this place.
It looks like a dump and you don't even
know it's there.
But he's fantastic with doing suspension
and tweaking these cars out.
And they set it up for my weight and
everything and dropped it and lowered it
and set all the suspensions.
Your physical way because you're a
heavier guy,
right?
So because you have to to,
to adjust for that 250 pounds sitting in
the driver's seat and how that affects
suspension.
So do they have like an asymmetric
suspension?
Is that what it is?
Like one side is like at a different
height or something?
Yes,
slightly to keep it basically is have
your fat ass sit in there and then
fucking adjust to adjust.
And I take the measurements and then do
the adjustments as need be.
And uh,
my cat,
my buddy chris from kw and he works with
all the drift guys like dai yoshihara
and all them and sets their suspensions
up and everything comes up with trick,
different ways of doing it.
What is the whole drift movement?
What is that about?
Why do people like to go sideways and
cars basically will one because it looks
cool,
right?
It does look pretty,
it looks fuckinG cool.
I think I would call drift the
different,
like the combination of stunt driving
and racing because they have to go fast
enough through it.
They've got to do,
but they've got a.
It's not just about going sideways
because they do it in those tandems,
so the idea is like to try and match
your and get as close and as tight into
any late.
The guys run in front of you as tight as
possible without hitting him,
hitting the wall,
hitting anything else,
and doing it as fast and as skillful as
possible.
So I look at it,
I'm like,
it's just like a violent auto ballet.
That's funny.
That's a funny way.
It's a really fun too.
So they've got like djs and it's like a
huge party the whole day.
Long island auto belay,
violent,
automatic.
How do they judge?
It's based on judge on a speed.
They look at the speed.
They look at how now they have these
clipping point things,
so they've got these lights that will
monitor up if you get within a foot of
them with your car.
So they measure how close you get to
these clipping points.
They also measure how closely you follow
the.
You hit the right apex is in lines for
the drips,
but also how closely and tightly you
follow the guy ahead of you.
The lead car in the fall and you're as
the follow car,
so a lot of crashes.
There's a decent amount of wacky stuff.
Yeah.
ShIt.
I mean,
but they're not catastrophic.
But yeah,
they,
most of their body panels or title and
zip ties,
they just fucking rip right off.
Oh really?
Yeah.
On purpose.
We'll just so that because we have all
these fucking zoots fittings all over
the place,
locked in there and it gets torn.
No instead,
now just breaks it some little spot and
falls off real easy.
So instead of tearing like a whole bunch
of fairing off of the car or something
and just tears off a little,
like the bumper rips off and you can go
ahead and fix that real quick and zip it
right back on again.
That's interest.
So there's sort of like altered them to
deal with the constant collision.
Yeah.
Well and like there are some amazing
moments where someone's coming through
a,
uh,
come up against the wall and they're,
they're getting that back end out and
they get so close with their back end,
hits the wall just enough to fold it in.
And when they come off,
it pops back out.
I mean,
that's holy shit dude.
You,
you literally ran your car into the
wall,
but just enough that it was still okay.
Okay.
Well one day there's going to be.
Every car is going to be like a gtr
where everything is calculated to going
to see things coming in
except it's not going to go that fast.
And the governments can tell you where
to drive.
That's going to be a real problem,
isn't it?
You know,
I had heard something about,
I don't know if this is a true story,
I never really researched it,
but someone was really driving really
fast on the highway and the cops,
um,
called a,
what is it?
Onstar.
And they shut the car.
Is that true?
Uh,
I think that is,
is that really possible?
See,
that seems to me to be.
I'm not people getting aWay from the
cops either,
but I am not also for the fucking
skynet.
Shut your car off.
Know that drives me nuts.
like if you have a problem,
there's one thing is to,
to,
to deal with the problem.
And then he is to take it so,
so much further that all of a sudden
everybody's freedoms are impinged.
That's not okay.
Yeah.
The fact that I'd rather have to deal
with cops chasing somebody down,
even if it ended up in my house getting
ruined because of it.
Then having the big brother able to make
everybody do everything the way they
want to.
Every time.
Absolute power corrupts absolutely.
And I was talking to this gal and she's
going,
oh,
I would love it if cars start driving
themselves.
So they were talking about that magnetic
system where they had the cars following
and traffic and stopping and slowing
down and you know,
reducing accidents.
And I think safety is great,
but life is dangerous,
period.
We don't,
we die everyday.
That's part of the time.
Yeah.
You know what cormac mccarthy talked
about the,
the,
about everything is about games,
uh,
in this booklet and marine.
And then he goes on about how it's,
you know,
games,
men love games,
boys love games,
but what they love,
the thing about a game that makes it
more important or less is what's at
stake.
So war being the ultimate game because
death is at stake if and that is the
ultimate ultimate wager is life and it's
true.
If there was no consequences for the
things that for a lot of the things that
we did,
there would be no that wouldn't have any
meaning.
Of course getting into the ring and
fighting somebody with no consequence of
injury or death or whatever wouldn't
wouldn't hold nearly as much interest.
It wouldn't have the same meaning behind
it.
And then it has to be very careful
because the samurai fighting starts
becoming really popular and do start
actually sword fighting.
Then people aren't gonna.
Watch mma especially.
I think there's a whole collection of
sword fighting videos right now.
I think it's put as a boy with cox.
Oh yeah.
Do you think that there's a.
That I could do?
Well,
I dunno.
Was like night of the warrior fighting
with swords.
Is that possible for us to go back down
to like the romans and the christians to
the lions and all that stuff?
Not yet.
Not yet,
but anything's possible.
Right?
I mean,
come on,
look it.
Look at the way that the government is
today versus where it was saying,
and in the fifties or in the 19,
early 19 hundreds,
it's much more intrusive by far our,
by far and,
or just look at how radical tastes may
change in terms of what content you'll
see on television versus what you would
see,
let's say even in the most risky part of
the twenties and thirties.
Technology of course,
always has a lot to do with that.
You know,
you have cameras and that anybody can
use the shoe.
So of course it's much easier to make
porn than it was back in when you had an
edison machine or whatever.
Yeah,
you actually had a day.
You gotta you gotta have a good strong
arm and you gotta you gotta have
coordinates that jerk off and wind a
wheel at the same time.
Uh,
but,
but look at if you just turn into
regular advertising,
I mean,
it's,
it's amazing that there are just men
jerking off on corners everywhere they
go because there's so much sex being
thrown at you all the time.
The best way to sell.
And uh,
and how much we can get away with in
terms of flesh and,
and provocative,
whatever and,
and what.
And we see these things as being an,
I don't have anything against any of
this,
but back in the thirties,
like people would have an aneurysm
unthought of to see something like that
and it just things progress.
Now.
Could things progressed to where people
are really sort of fighting?
I don't know.
I suppose so.
And they have to have a few natural
disasters.
People wanted to sword fight.
Shouldn't they be allowed to?
I think if they choose to do it,
if they choose to do it,
yeah.
If they choose to do it,
if,
if people want,
they want the ultimate contests.
I mean,
it's not like if they don't do that,
they're gonna live forever.
There are temporary being if you choose
to go out that actually
as a highlander,
I have to sword fight to live forever.
That's the only way,
right?
There can be only one.
Of course.
Josh barnett.
Ladies and gentlemen,
this is a bit of fun podcast,
dude.
Thanks for very much.
My pleasure.
Great to come back on.
Oh please.
Anytime.
Definitely.
And when,
so you said about three months before
people can look forward to seeing you
very much before you can go back into
training.
Uh,
hard to say I got to follow up on friday
but I mean I've got good range of motion
in it but I do want to take,
I know that that's going to take a
little longer to cut this back open and
I don't like surgery.
I don't want to get cut open.
I don't want to go under but I just
think in the long run it's going to be a
lot better.
So you have to do that soon and then you
have to recover from that.
Yeah.
And you know,
I,
I'm even looking into like there's like
what can they do for bone density,
you know,
nowadays and I mean this is my
livelihood.
I need to make sure if this shit doesn't
happen again.
What kennedy can you.
I was having online about micro wars
because there's any fucking.
I think so those kinda,
those cannot punch just about anything
there.
And there's like chinese iron palm
techniques and these people work on it
and so it seems like it would condition
your hands the war or those kinds of
giant knuckles and it seems like that
would help little.
I've seen documentary the duties.
He hits a little piece of steel
everyday.
Fu dude is legit,
man.
The guy he doesn't feel to look at doing
something like that and like,
you know,
what forms of calcium or whatever.
There was supposedly something called
forteo out there which was a bone
density drug.
Really.
They give it to us,
throw the women with osteoporosis with
high a likelihood of fracture.
Wow.
And it might be able to like a healthy
person,
jack up your bone density I suppose.
I mean,
the thing is we're losing bone density
day.
Yeah.
That is a problem with getting older,
with fighting the power man,
fighting it.
Really
every,
every cell that we have in our body is
constantly being attacked and they will
degenerate over time and can't live
forever.
But uh,
when you,
while you're here,
you'd like to be able to use it as much
as possible.
Holding noman 34,
34.
How much longer are you thinking of me
throwing down so I can't tell.
You can't tell the fucking fucking.
Yeah,
bloody my hands for the last breath.
Be torn for me because as much as you
fucking.
This isn't the only amount of time you
have in your life to do this and
fighting is me.
I am a fighting is absolutely a part of
who I am,
violence,
a part of my life and that I'm.
I've got a lot more to me than that.
But being in the ring and being in war,
that's what I'm saying.
There's a lot of guys who say that and
you go,
okay,
and do to keep convincing yourself.
When you say that josh barnett is
telling the fucking truth,
that's exactly what you feel.
That's exactly what you mean when you're
saying it.
You're,
you're 100 percent committed and
convicted to it.
It's a.
And I told someone the other day,
I go,
when I go to the
ring,
I'm already dead.
I go to the ring is a dead person.
I have no feelings.
I have no emotions.
I don't care about anyone,
I don't care about anything.
I don't care about my life anymore.
I don't have it.
I,
I have a little set list of songs I
listened to you in my,
my hotel room before I go to and I,
you know,
like a couple tiers might fall from my
eyes.
I don't,
without out any sound,
just you know,
just out of nowhere.
I just,
and I know that those tiers are for the
life that I no longer own,
that it is gone.
I am dead now.
I'm more into my life and is no longer
exist.
I am this,
this is me right now.
I'm walking the life of a dead person
and the only way to go is to go out
there and let's go to the death.
It's just I have nothing to lose because
I have nothing anymore.
There is nothing.
I feel nothing.
I care for nothing.
And in the middle of that,
it's going to be the most intense
feeling of all time.
When you,
when you're in the middle of the cage,
like your last fight,
the most recent will call me and you,
you guys are both throwing down and and
you both had broken hands at that point
in time.
It's got to be one of the most intense
and realistic forms of struggle on her.
It is,
but unfortunately that's where it's
great where your corner man can,
can give you that input to,
to,
to aim your direction because I got on
there and broke my hand,
made a couple fucked up a couple times
in there and then all of a sudden I went
into fight to the death mode,
but it's not a fight to the death.
It's a fight for five rounds.
If you don't finish it in five,
chances are on those.
So I didn't really.
I mean,
yeah,
people looking at you like,
oh,
you're like blonde blood out of your
nose and just,
you know,
you're coming out.
People never stopped coming forward and
trying to murder.
I'm like,
right,
but in front of three judges,
a referee and five rounds,
it didn't work.
So I got paid less.
And you know,
think there's still a learning process.
It is,
and I know it's,
it's a,
yeah,
it is a learning process,
but I know that for me,
being like that feeling that way,
that's,
that's there's days I feel like most of
the time I feel like that's the way I
really am.
That's when I get my strip off.
Everything that society has imparted on
me and him and parts on me like pushes
on and be like that.
I throw it all away and it to.
I tell you what,
feeling like your dead is pretty free.
You really feel free.
You've never appreciated life more when
you've already given it away.
It makes sense.
Yeah.
That makes sense.
It's as intense as things can get.
There's no,
there's no other way.
Right.
I mean that is as intense.
It's nothing other than actual war
itself,
you know,
there's nothing more intense.
No.
And uh,
it,
it also,
I think,
you know,
you start getting a bad.
It's like the,
I'm gonna try and do something.
You just do it.
If there's something that must be done,
you do it.
You just do it.
And uh,
you can,
you don't,
everything doesn't have to always be to
the level of know,
um,
you know,
the walking dead and,
and I don't have any emotion or feeling
anymore.
I had a girl I was in love with,
break the living shit out of my heart as
soon as I had to go off over to Japan
and I had pro wrestling matches to do
and stuff and I'm destroyed inside.
I'm totally ruined and I'm giving press
conferences and shit like that.
And you know,
they need to see a hero.
But inside I just feel like a piece of
shit,
you know,
I feel terrible and I'll go out there
and wrestle.
Matt and I had a wrestling match in
front of 12,000
people and make it look amazing.
And I did and we fucking,
we tore the house down.
But it was a,
it was like,
you know what?
You feel like death right now.
You feel like the lowest form and your
heart is so broken,
but nobody paid for that.
So it doesn't really matter how you
feel.
Right now you have this in front of you.
And this must be accomplished and you
can anybody make,
excuse you for cIrcumstances,
but that's.
No sorry.
There really is no excuse.
there is only the result and only you
know,
whether you do it or you don't.
What's it like for you to see guys that
you came up with?
Guys like pedro,
his own that have reached pretty much
the end and you see the end and did,
do you,
uh,
do you take like a mental account?
Dionte
have there ever been training even
because I'm tired of getting hit in the
head by fucking monsters that are in
there.
And I just,
I know that part of the reason I tried
to read as much as I do and I do want to
Be a more,
well everyday that I have a chance to be
a better person and learn more and be,
have a broader sense of this world at
large,
um,
is necessary.
It's important.
I think that's part of my,
uh,
not just right as a person to do so.
But I think it's a necessity.
Like you,
you should have to do that.
Uh,
but it's also the stable way,
the effects of that kind of shit of
dementia and whatever.
I mean I'm getting mad and practice
constantly and then I go in the ring and
get hit in the head some more and,
and it damages your brain.
There's no way around it.
Some people are more susceptible to the
side effects of it,
of catching pugilistic dementia and the
different becoming punchdrunk and,
but I know that there've been times
where I find myself trying to catch a
word and I'm like,
I don't know why I can't think of that
right now,
but that's maybe,
maybe it's because I'm getting hit in
the head by eric prindle who's 300
pounds,
but so why not just save it,
save that brain so that I can use more
of it and even I'm still going to be
getting hit in the head no matter what
headgear I have on me.
But,
uh,
I don't want to take things to the point
where I've made a disability for myself
mentally or physically with fighting.
uh,
do you think you'll be able to discern
that?
I think I'll be.
I think if I'm honest,
I will,
um,
and,
but why watch guys like pedro can't take
a punch like he used to and part of me
feels bad when you know,
I,
I do feel sad for that,
where they're at now compared to where
they used to be,
but I'm also more so happy that they are
here on this earth,
loving their life,
still being able to exert themselves in
the ring and be a part of this.
And if they decide to retire or when it
comes to that point,
they need to retire.
That they did it,
that they had the opportunity to live
that life.
They took those experiences into
themselves and they can stand there in
front of anybody and go,
I did this.
I made my mistakes.
I had my success is I did this.
I did it with everything I got.
And you know what,
you can't take any of that away from me
ever.
It's all mine.
And I earned it.
And that's beautiful,
powerful wisdom from josh barnett,
ladies and gentlemen.
And with that note,
that's the end of this podcast.
The real end of this product.
This is the first time we ever did a
podcast like this for folks listening.
this is gonna sound weird.
A,
it might sound a little different
because we're using a totally different
setup.
We had a some sort of electrical
shortage and brian got zapped in the
face with a fucking lightning bolt,
but uh,
yeah,
it was,
it was white sparks,
too busy trying to run my car into the
fucking divider and wall on 1:10
north.
Well,
there was a lot involved in making this
podcast happened,
but it did happen.
So thank you very much sir.
I really appreciate it.
Thanks again to our sponsors.
Thanks to the flashlight.
Go to joe rogan.net.
Click on the link for the fleshlight.
Entering the code name,
rogan.
Save yourself 15 percent off the number
one sex toy for men.
Thanks.
It's true for real.
That's our sponsor.
Thanks to a on it.com,
o n n I t,
makers of alpha brain,
shroom,
tech,
sport room,
immune and new mood.
The five htp supplement.
Did you not even just the hole,
a mushroom blend.
Their mushrooms are very healthy.
Yeah,
there's a lot of really healthy
mushrooms.
Uh,
we also have a kettle bells and battle
ropes all for sale.
Now go to [inaudible] dot com.
And if you use a codename brogan,
you will save 10 percent off all
supplements.
So go get some.
Thank you josh barnett.
That's the end tonight.
You'd already been just.
Oh,
file josh on twitter.
It's josh barnett.
B a r n e t t.